they say there was no red wave well I
don't care what they say I think there
was I mean the Republicans won 5 million
more uh votes in the popular vote and
they won where they needed to in the
house now the Republicans have announced
they've launched an investigation of Joe
Biden this is not just a funder but it
is of the Biden crime family at least
that's what's trending on Twitter I know
it's a little silly because it kind of
makes it seem like the bidens are
competent but uh yeah Joe and Hunter are
implicating a bunch of crimes the
craziest Revelation I suppose and I
guess we kind of knew this but to hear
them say it the Biden family is
implicated in human trafficking
seriously this this guy's the president
okay oh that'll get interesting so uh we
definitely got to talk about that but we
also need to talk about Nancy Pelosi
she's out Nancy Pelosi has announced you
will not seek the Democratic Leadership
but she's going to stay in congress for
the time being but basically nothing
there you go bye-bye Nancy Pelosi fired
so hey congratulations midterm this is
what happens when you get your friends
you go out and you vote now all you got
to do is get ready for that ballot
harvesting stuff so we got a lot to talk
about we'll talk about all that but
before we do my friends head over to
establishedtitles.com
timcastirl you can get one of these
really cool things right here it's a
plaque I'm a lord lord Tim Poole I
expect everyone to use my proper title
No but uh established titles is
basically you buy a piece of land in the
Scottish woodlands and then it makes you
a Scottish Lord established titles.com
timcastirl
and uh they say it's a Project based on
a historic Scottish custom where land
owners are referred to as Lords and
Ladies so if you're a lady you can be
lady officially
their title packs give you at least one
square foot of dedicated land with a
unique plot number on a private estate
in edelston Scotland and an official
certificate with a Crest to add to that
they're also a fun novel way to preserve
the natural Woodlands of Scotland while
helping Global reforestation efforts
they actually will they'll actually
plant a tree with every order working
with global Charities like one tree
planted in trees for the future the
first 200 people purchasing a title pack
using my link will effectively be next
to my plot within a few minutes walking
distance very cool established titles is
actually running a massive Black Friday
sale right now and if you use the code
timcast IRL you get an additional 10 off
so go to established titles.com
timcastirl get your gifts now it's a
cool thing you can send people you can
get stuff in their name and you know I
got mine right here so you know very
very cool thank you established titles
for sponsoring the show established
titles.comcast IRL don't forget head
over to timcast.com become a member
support the show directly we're gonna
have a members only show coming up for
you after the main show show ends so we
usually post those around 11 pm they're
a lot of fun not family friendly
uncensored all that good stuff so don't
forget to smash that like button right
now subscribe to this channel share the
show if you really do like it word of
mouth is the most powerful way to
overcome the censorship joining us
tonight we have two amazing guests we've
got Ashley Sinclair hello hello who are
you I am you know a professional online
crap poster um but more important family
friendly yeah I don't want you to get uh
nuked online
um so but I'm over at The Babylon B I do
operations over there oh very cool and
get in trouble for my tweets it's called
fecal matter poster I'm a fecal matter
poster that's right that's right and we
also have Dave Landau hi I'm chewing why
are you chewing what are you eat I'm
professional those are Ian's rocks don't
eat them stop I thought they were magic
I'm playing Magic the Gathering with
this stuff he's gonna start tripping in
two minutes no yeah oh there's acid in
this
um uh there would be there would be yeah
yeah I heard him talking about acid with
Milo on the show the other day
Milo just basically told him his brain
was broken and the end just went yeah I
was like no I agree I've done a lot of
acid and I was like he's right they're
both right yeah I mean he didn't
disagree so also I'm search.com what's
up guys how are you we got Luke
bidenfetterman.com is the website it's a
real website you could go to it right
now if you don't you're a bigot ableist
and racist did you actually get Biden
fetterman.com is an official website
filled with memes filled with Twitter
posts filled with shorts and filled with
this amazing incredible merchandise I
started a movement a couple months ago
and I have a lot of good allies on my
team first it's Michael malice then it's
MSNBC this is a movement of the people
that cannot be stopped it's an absolute
no-brainer Biden fetterman 2020. I can't
believe you I know you actually got and
the crazy thing is Biden fetterman 2024
was not available
we got it check that website out and by
doing so you support uh my efforts here
so thank you so much for doing so
bidenfetterman.com the car salesman
slogan is fantastic
it's a no-brainer all right let's talk
about the uh let's let's uh talk about
the news from Newsweek from Newsweek of
all sources I know Republicans tie
Hunter bite into human trafficking
announce probe let me pause right there
they explicitly stated this is an
investigation of Joe Biden so Newsweek
they're talking about it but they're
trying to you know maybe the goal with
the article is to be like it's Hunter
not Joe right but uh you know I'll be
specific they said they were announcing
an investigation into Joe they didn't
specifically say Joe Biden was
trafficking people although I think he
was with the illegal immigrants yes he
was well okay never mind he was was this
broken by Geek Squad or who did it which
one it just depends on the source which
which was it a computer that was
returned like who knows where did they
get the Intel uh actually I think it was
um some Republicans in Tennessee who
filmed the uh children being trafficked
on U.S military planes around the
country by the Biden Administration so
oh right no no I I mean he literally was
trafficking children oh good for him I
thought it was the hunter sex Russian
prostitute thing oh no I mean yes yeah I
don't mean to leave it clean for the
family friendly people watching it's
just they're called ladies of the night
I'm sorry and you know Hunter Biden did
love ladies of the night particularly
from Russia which you know a lot of
people were going crazy about
specifically speculating that Donald
Trump had relations with in some kind of
hotel rooms but but again here we
actually have some real life proof of of
Hunter Biden taking videos and photos of
some absolutely crazy behavior that do
violate a lot of laws Lady of the night
I mean I feel like you know it's it's
archaic maybe something like adult
physical therapist lady who puts down a
tarp
I think a lot of these videos of Hunter
were you know during the day yeah so you
know it you know just adult physical
therapy we'll just call it that you know
some blood into morning I mean literally
bleeding I love that he vlogged the
whole thing too the whole thing is well
documented he's like he's like the new
David dobrik you know he's he's an
artist he he's ahead of his times and
it's really incredible you know the
simulator Verte that he presented to the
general public truly an artist of our of
our time my favorite is the Eminem photo
if you haven't seen the Eminem it was
measuring a member of his with M M's
and Hunter took a picture of it he was I
don't want to look at those pictures
I was like this is going to be my
wallpaper
yeah he did okay well let's let's let's
let's see what they're talking about
well they're specifically looking into a
number of charges they're looking to see
if they could charge him with conspiracy
or defrauding the United States why are
fraud conspiracy to commit wire fraud
violation of the foreign agents
registration act violation of the
foreign corruption Practices Act
violation of the victims of trafficking
and violence protection act of 2000 tax
evasion money laundering and conspiracy
to commit money laundering those are the
charges those are what they're looking
into Joe uh I I think Hunter and Joe
since uh this Newsweek article this
Newsweek article talks about how they
had bank accounts that were co-mingled
together uh they obviously also shared
phone numbers they obviously also were
in business together it's pretty clear
no matter how many times Joe Biden tries
to deny this it's very clear that there
was a lot of communication a lot of back
and forth business dealings a lot of Air
Force too a lot of lucrative contracts
in Ukraine and in China that he was not
supposed to get that he got along of
course with his vlogging of smoking
crack being with ladies of the night and
having firearms everywhere one firearm
that he left outside of a school zone
which he got in trouble for
the way George tried to hide a cannoli
on Seinfeld I just want to I just want
to simplify this for everybody really
quick
um
outside of all of this I'm sure there's
gonna be a bunch of people on the left
or you know Democrats desperately trying
to defend Joe being like this is
nonsense it's fake news it's so
Preposterous but they shared bank
accounts and right there is the is the
morsel of whoa whoa whoa cause let me
tell you something yo I tried to buy my
mom like a toaster and my account is
like you can't do that like you you
cannot have like you you give something
to somebody it is a gift it is tracked
it goes towards that if you share a bank
account you're making it like basically
impossible to track how much you're
giving to another person there's no
circumstance where I I guess if if Joe
Biden and Hunter Biden were both
officers of a corporation or some some
something like that and they both had
executive access to a bank account that
could make sense but hey hold on there a
minute that would mean that Joe Biden
lied and was directly involved in
business with his son otherwise it just
sounds like some weird at the very least
tax evasion or you know income
commingling which is already a problem
the human trafficking is definitely
related to the ladies of the night he
was he he bought a lot of them and
especially from Eastern Europe who knows
if some people might speculate that he
was swallowed uh that's also another
possibility here but but
he was picking them out like it was a
Wendy's menu he was saying I don't like
this one you know take the lettuce off
of that one he really wanted picking
them out on these text messages it was
well documented yeah but you might do
want to say you said the left is going
to come out and say it's not true I
don't know that they're going to say
much of anything to be honest I think
they're just going to ignore it because
that's what they do when they these
things come out that there's a mountain
of evidence they just ignore it hey at
least though did they well who knows you
know I think there were a lot of them
yeah exactly how much Intel are you
going to get with really just a half
hour each yeah but but the caveat here
at least we give big Tech social media
something to censor in the future just
like the hunter Biden laptop story at
least now we're gonna have the sensors
at Facebook and Twitter and Instagram
busy with more work so at least you know
they're gonna have something to do I
hear you but I'm actually kind of
optimistic you know Facebook came out
and said they're not going to be fact
checking Trump's campaign because he's
running or something like that Elon Musk
buys Twitter
so I'm kind of like I think I think
maybe they they you know the the the
extremists shot their shot and and they
can't keep that up at a certain point
you're trying to hold back a day like a
a river and the damn bursts yes you know
they censor everything we all know the
scandal of the hunter Biden laptop
censorship they they can't pull that off
again I mean can they well it's filled
with everything he just said
with Republicans controlling the house
if all we get is Nancy Pelosi is fired
and they launched his investigation this
investigation alone is going to make it
impossible YouTube took down C-SPAN
videos of Rand Paul talking because he
said a naughty name no now if they're
all saying it they can't just if YouTube
started Banning C-SPAN outright people
might be like hey wait a minute they
took down one video and hope nobody
noticed they took down a Fox News video
and hoped that nobody's nobody nobody
noticed but if they've if they're going
to have a committee putting out videos
if they're gonna have a January 6 style
inquiry ain't nothing they can do about
it we'll see spin after dark's pretty
hot I hope they do a j6 trial for this
you know a stock a j6 style
investigation they should do the whole
nine they should put the hunter Biden
laptop contents on the screen for the
whole world to stay I don't know exactly
absolutely evidence it's all there it's
all vlogged by Hunter Biden on truck
it's all there that's a lot to see
though my my favorite C-SPAN after dark
was when all the all the Democrats
called in saying they were quitting the
party you guys remember that that was
crazy it was a few years ago but it was
just like I remember pulling the video
up and pressing play and it was just a
guy being like I don't know what they're
doing they lost their minds I'm voting
Republican now and I'm like wow but
there's also a possibility that we might
find something even more Sinister I
think there's a big probability for this
as well because when we look at what's
been happening throughout the last few
years the FBI knew a lot of this was
happening they had the laptop they had
interviews with Tony bobolinski they
chose to of course censor and cover it
up what was inside of that laptop what
are also the very weird photos with
children inside of that laptop which I I
think is something that could
essentially be something that will shock
the American public to the point where
there's no returning from it and I think
there's a possibility of that happening
maybe the maybe the game is to slow roll
it to the point where everyone's heard a
little bit without getting shocked too
much so when they when they finally come
out and admit it everyone's gonna be
like well yeah dude we know well they
also rated giuliani's house and he's
like it's right here and they're like no
we came for everything else yep yeah
where she had the laptop he had the
hunter Biden laptop with the weird
photos of the the children yeah let's be
honest here it would have been funny if
it would have been sorry it would have
been funny if they were arrested
Giuliani for possession yeah just
they're like oh you got those images but
there's
but you got it yeah it's on you it's not
just Hunter though it's also I mean that
whole family's Disturbed all of his
children are very disturbed her a lot
the Ashley Biden diary was one of the
most disturbing things I ever read and
after I read it I felt bad yeah
but I don't think we could read it
online
she talks about showering with her
father that whole family is disturbing
right my grandfather Yeah she talked
about how she had to shower at night
because she was afraid Biden was going
to come into the shower with her yeah
yes that's what is it in there what if
when Biden broke his leg it wasn't the
dog but like his granddaughter this was
or some kind of child fighting back be
like no could be who knows nowadays
especially with you know the island that
they all go to especially you know since
the island closed down they gotta you
know I think he was probably just
fighting back the nurses he's like don't
put it in and again I'm ready to go
powdery bones and that man is not filled
with calcium remember when uh during the
Alex Jones trial the prosecution was
like you think that the powerful Global
Elites are trafficking children and he
goes what you mean like Epstein and they
did with the clintons and then they made
the thug life video now if anyone ever
brings that up they're like oh you
believe some weird conspiracy about you
know Elites trafficking people I'll be
like you mean like the investigation the
Republicans have opened into the Biden
family yeah like look you can call it a
conspiracy but then you gotta you have
to contend with the fact that the
majority of Congress is investigating
that so yeah they're a cult like I I
rewatched that Sam Harris clip where
he's like there is nothing on the hunter
Biden laptop that is bad as Trump
University
and I'm like my guy there's like illicit
pictures of children you're saying that
Donald Trump scammed some people out of
cash the bidens are implicated in human
trafficking Sam Harris he lost his mind
yeah yeah absolutely and like you
compare the two there's no comparison
what about Trump's Stakes
[Laughter]
actually and you know it's you know it's
funny too I remember I wasn't serious
well no no look during Trump's campaign
they were saying that all of his
businesses failed and it was the
weirdest thing they were like what
happened to Trump water what happened to
Trump Stakes or Trump magazine and I was
sitting in Trump Doral in Florida
looking at a bottle of trump water with
a trump magazine and a menu showing
Trump steak and I'm like do these people
not understand the companies he started
our suppliers for his his hotels like he
doesn't sell Trump's stake in the
grocery store he's making his own stuff
so he lowers his costs right it's it's
just so insane and I think out of like
500 businesses five went bankrupt and so
they're like look at all those
bankruptcies it's okay dude you believe
you Google it okay come on they don't
they don't even do that no it's sad very
sad when you have other billionaires
that were just kind of mad about it
because he was president and it was kind
of watched it was fun to watch them
project how angry they were because I
didn't think it would happen she just
had like Mark Cuban like it's all failed
you're Mark Cuban yeah let's talk about
this next story if there's anything good
that came out of these midterms Nancy
Pelosi will step down as Democratic
house leader finally oh yeah all right
Pelosi you're out you're fired and uh
okay she says she wants to make room for
the next generation and uh it's it's
just as bad you know they're the same
who is it Hank Jeffries or something so
I don't know man are you guys
she's fired well she she's gotta go
spend more time at home so Paul stops
picking up young men is that what he was
doing well it's a theory you know you
don't want to say for sure but maybe he
got hit with a hammer by one I heard by
somebody maybe possibly depends on which
underwear no no no they changed that
story
oh so it's just I think Paul was in his
underwear actually you bring a feral cat
in the house and you want it to be nice
but it's got a hammer you know that that
is sad too because I you know I kind of
get it we have bogus he's our cat yeah
and he was initially a stray and he just
he just pisses all over the floor all
the time and like there's no training
him he's a he's a he'll just like walk
and they'll look you in the eyes and
just let her let her rip so I get it
when when Paul brings in these guys and
he's like a crazy hippie and he's like
we're gonna we're gonna have a good time
cracking that with a hammer so he who's
who was the third party
that opened the door didn't end up being
him yeah yeah but who was there what
were you saying before there was a young
man in his car so that's what I heard
that when he got arrested for the DUI
there was another man with him there was
a young man with him
yeah I heard it was dropped I could be
wrong but that's what he was arrested
for right he was entertaining a young
man uh I don't know what they were doing
getting away from Nancy
who caught them wrestling
in their underwear yes it's a very
popular sport you know a lot of people
are doing it over a hammer I I just it's
about time that she left though I mean
everything she was getting pretty
incoherent as well oh that's called uh
addiction to benzos yeah is that what it
is and painkillers because she has to be
on something she's on everything listen
to her when she walks it just sounds
like she's a drunk right yo for sure I
don't know people have said that I I
mean her husband I think is he got in a
car accident well when Bine did the
speech and then she stood up and was
like dancing behind him when he was
talking about like people dying and then
she realized she was like oh this isn't
the part where I celebrate that's when I
realized like oh this is a just a drunk
woman at a tennis club who doesn't
really know where she is like I think
the point at which she probably should
have retired that's why she started
talking like this yeah it's like okay
come on so oh five yeah no I'm not even
kidding he's like
so who's going to be the next answer
who's going to be the next Nancy Pelosi
for them though I think it's this guy
what's his name Hank Jeffrey is that his
name am I getting his name wrong you
guys probably know in the chat
I don't know
some some election denying far left
lunatic whatever he denies the election
oh they all do they all they all did I
mean like every single Democrat denied
the election there was a there was a
Snopes article I think it was no I think
it was PolitiFact and um I'm not sure
who said it might have been uh lee
zeldin or something said that
Democrats have objected or or rejected
the the results of every Republican
president going back like several
decades or something and then they were
like mostly true mostly true and it's
like how is that not true they literally
do they get up and they say this is
illegitimate there was voters who were
disenfranchised or whatever and then
we're supposed to just act like
they're not lying when they call other
people election deniers or something
we do it one time and had one party at
the Capitol and everything that's what
they're waiting for but that's the thing
we're talking about eleven two is what
you're referring to we were talking
about it earlier you know that uh
they just the left acts like it doesn't
happen if if the hunter Biden laptop
stuff it comes out it's a mountain of
evidence we can all see it they just
plug their plug their ears close their
eyes and walk away and then say what are
you talking about I'm just talking about
yep and that's it so uh we're supposed
to engage with that I don't know this is
why I'm my attitude has kind of just
been like let's perhaps ignore them and
let them just play by themselves with
dolls in the corner or something I'm
with you yeah because they seem when
left alone they do a lot of crazy fun
stuff that we can just bring up later
yeah like fetterman yeah oh yeah
we elected Frankenstein you know which
I'm for by the way I want to say oh yeah
we're on the team awesome
so I think he's better than ours but
that's a different story is it like an
accelerationist thing well I mean we I
mean I think that's why a lot of people
voted for Trump in the beginning they're
like let the system burn down let it
burn down quick might as well put all
the crazy people and and you know might
as well put all the incompetent people
in there I mean they can't do worse than
all the crazy sociopathic people right
that's what I'm saying I was saying uh
antifa for Trump yeah you know I'm
telling these intimate people like hey
you guys are going out and throwing
bricks through Windows that's not gonna
do anything they got insurance it's
going to cost them a couple Grand
they're going to fix it should you do
vote for Trump right now I know Trump
supporters are like but hold on there a
minute Trump's going to fix the country
sure that's not what they think they
think he's going to burn it down right
so just hey vote for him what he got to
lose yeah you're already ruining the
country
it's a sinking ship what are you gonna
try to save it yeah come on stop it so
uh antifa for Biden fetterman well you
made a great Point can he drive we don't
know I don't think federmen can drive if
they take your license for that yes
after you have a stroke in Pennsylvania
and that's and that's not knocking
that's something ableist we're just
saying a fact
I mean a little bit like if you can't
drive you probably shouldn't be in
Senate I mean I don't think next people
also can drive can't you well not well
her husband definitely can not after
like oh yeah not after you know her
morning Mimosa all right that's what I
mean basically she's old and she drinks
too much and so she's probably she's got
someone driving for her yeah she
shouldn't drive isn't there like a law
where they take your license after a
certain age or something yeah I think
well I think yeah they take your license
after a certain age yeah I'm pretty sure
I think it depends on the state yeah it
depends on this right right right
Florida you can drive forever oh yeah
well that's gonna be crazy a lot of
retirees down there they're not going to
entertain people voting away their right
to drive or whatever but there are there
are a lot of sad stories of people who
like their eyesight goes and their their
reflexes you know reaction time goes
down and then they're driving a car and
I don't know man you got over shop well
I mean I know I know a crazy story back
from my neighborhood of a teenage girl
who got hit by an old guy and then he
rolls over her stops IT panics that he
runs over so he reverses Crush out like
a melon oh no if he just went over her
she probably would have had severe
injuries but he crushed her head because
and so his life all that happened
license taken away no jail
oh but here's the issue with with jail
on that in that circumstance
is he of the mind to commit a crime or
is he just an old man who should not be
driving anymore and so the attitude I
guess from law enforcement was he's not
a violent criminal who's trying to hurt
people he's effectively disabled by age
so take his license away he can't drive
anymore but he's not going to jail for
that is that why none of these
politicians go to jail for doing
everything they shouldn't they're like
they're all we'll give them a pass there
was no intense they're just crazy you
know but that's that that is it often
it's like well there was no Criminal
Intent so you know no crime committed
that's what happens with the human
trafficking they're like he didn't know
that little rascal yeah yes it was a
Menendez right he went out with those uh
he went he went to that Island uh it
wasn't Epstein Island but remember the
story you guys know the story about
Menendez with the like where was he was
he in Puerto Rico or something and he
went to some Island and there were some
ladies and they're a little young you
know and then he got accused and the
response from his lawyer was well it's
not illegal where he was
oh okay yeah well I mean technically but
the lawyer said like even if he did do
it it's not illegal like he's in
different country I had to call my
lawyer
do you what
wow that's disgusting though I don't
know what yeah what are the laws well I
guess if you go down to Mexico there's
other laws
well yeah but there's some states I
think we're like the age of consent is
16. yeah yeah Michigan's one that's
right is that really yeah he goes I know
I grew up there no I didn't it was a
good one to have on the books oh high
school not you're really leaning into
this season
no I've been married for a long time you
look very cold I'm really cold do you
need a jacket I feel like he can't the
AC on in here I think it's I think it's
actually that nothing's on and it's like
30 degrees outside yeah I feel like
that's not tenable you don't look shaky
we've got a Chihuahua there's a coat
right there that is my coat oh well
there you go what is this you know
that's the thing about the air
conditioning in the office look who's
over here everybody turn the heat on
Luke is in a blanket oh thanks for
telling everyone my secret
camera yeah I got a blankie yeah
though I'm like real cold it's kind of
weird to me I mean I guess you're
wearing a sweater yeah I just grabbed
one from uh I don't know where I got it
I don't know why it's cold in here I
think it's because uh
the vent just pulls in air from outside
or something I think it is just yeah if
it's cold outside and you don't have
anything on that's what I do to sleep I
like it cold let's talk about that
that's interesting how do you sleep Tim
uh I put the AC to 32 degrees Yeah and
uh because if I don't really Igloo well
so uh a while back I um
my fiance was dying of a rare disease
okay and so I miss appropriate corporate
funds to try and research chronogenics
keeping her Frozen while I tried to find
a cure of course when he found out that
he came with thugs you know through the
the the the the chemicals and everything
splashed on me and now I have to live in
freezing temperatures otherwise I'll die
nice yeah yeah I once tried to uh I once
broke out of prison but you know Batman
stopped me that's cool that's what Tim
was trying to do now keep us all Frozen
so we stay on the show forever I can't
believe we're still talking about this
I'm a Mexican swam here in the last can
we can we it's a movie can we oh man we
gotta talk about Black Panther yes so
before before the show I was taught like
no one here saw wakanda forever and I
was explaining how the villain is a is a
basically a Mexican guy who breaks into
wakanda bypassing their wall by going
through the river and they have to
defeat him by drying him off
yep like I'm sorry if that was a big
spoiler I don't know but just like it's
been a week now and it was you know and
specifically his back goes into flames
you said they have to dry him off and
then the final move is they they dry his
back off yeah that's killing an Asian
with a hard math problem
I was sitting there watching this movie
like yo woke people were let's let's
talk about that later let's talk about
this okay I don't want to offend the
crap because big wakanda fans oh I know
I know um I I'm gonna have to ask that
Brianna Joy gray issues an apology for
this one
do you all know the legend of ligma and
Johnson
ligma and Johnson were two individuals
who went to Twitter HQ and walked out
carrying boxes and then started telling
reporters that they had been fired and
their names were like Rahul ligman like
Daniel Johnson or something get it ligma
Johnson and so uh the media got hoaxed
Elon Musk invited them back in to the
actually I think I have the Tweet right
here is it right here yeah Elon Musk
invited them back to Twitter HQ saying
welcoming back ligma and Johnson
and then uh this is a clip from the
hills Rising please listen I mean what
do you think this is about is it because
he has created such a poor working
environment has ruined the relationship
between him and his employees so much
that he's not able to do the job because
I saw him he was tweeting out pictures
of him standing with two employees who
had fired
prematurely and then rehires his arms
around them kind of like hey I know I I
shouldn't admit to my mistakes it seems
like he's in a desperate situation where
he's realized he actually needs somebody
and the single genius uh myth is just
that a myth and he actually needs these
employees to work for him and the
employees didn't look so happy in that
photograph I gotta say I mean I don't
know what this is Robbie Robbie what did
how how Daniel one of the hoaxsters says
how are we still tricking journalists
how is this still happening
yeah he's like I'm not sure Harry
belzania was also
and she's awesome
and she's also just saying like fired
early who's writing it and doesn't know
that this is amazing it's condescending
she is she's like we he thinks he's a
genius look how stupid he is yeah and
the hills like well I feel worse all of
it the hill the hill Rising used to be
crystal in uh uh Sagar right and now
it's uh Brianna Joy gray and Robbie
Suave I feel like these individuals
probably don't read
like
no and that's the problem with a lot of
the media and a lot of these journalists
now is they're not really journalists
they're like commentators on you know
what's hot and commentating on this this
photo that Elon Musk posted it's like
very pop culturally it's not actual news
she said she saw the photo okay right
yeah she said that yeah the photo says
ligma and Johnson on it
yes so she read that and then said it
went over her head you know the poor
woman Johnson come on this is a
family-friendly show here what do you
mean Tim what are you trying to say here
I'm trying to say that uh 12 year olds
are the ones who are pushing this joke
yeah literally
maybe that's I went over her head but
like she bought a hook line and stinker
yeah
this is the the modern State yes sorry
that's embarrassing this is the modern
state of media I guess
this is sad it's sad yeah and she did a
whole piece on it she was so proud of
herself too she was so emboldened have
they apologized she woke up and read
that and she's like what an idiot
this ligma Johnson guy
they didn't look happy in the photo yeah
the I think who's this is this ligma
that's ligma that's ligma uh does it say
legmon actually he he looks like a ligma
yeah yeah Johnson yeah Daniel he's got
name tags Rahul and Daniel and that's uh
Rahul ligma and Daniel Johnson he
doesn't Johnson doesn't sound right no
right yeah it doesn't or who ligma seems
rahulikma ligman Johnson the media got
hoax the first time Elon this is the
this is the craziest thing it's like the
people who like what Elon Musk is doing
understand the memes the jokes the
laughing
I don't get it right we talk about Nancy
Pelosi we talk about Hunter Biden the
laptop we know all of these things how I
don't how do we know these things and
okay you know what I'm going to stress
this point
the left and the right is not political
at all it is knowledge and ignorance if
you are stupid and not paying attention
you'll find yourself on the left if you
are interested and inquisitive you'll
find yourself on the right and I'm not
saying that if you're inquisitive all of
a sudden you're like I'm pro-life no you
you might end up being someone who's
like actually I'm pro-choice but yeah
Biden's crooked not your right wing now
I'm still laughing because this is not
the first time the corporate Media made
such mistakes and again we have to
remember according to YouTube these are
the authoritative sources we got to
believe them no matter what we gotta
Elevate them over everyone else do you
remember the the something Wong
airplane crash that happens
literally on Asian flight 214 that
literally went down we had KTVU a local
news broadcast go on national television
and say that the four Pilots or all of
those names in unison right there so so
yeah this should be a a big reality
check to a lot of people especially to
the you know the fact Checkers that
again the corporate media gets it wrong
they get it wrong a lot a lot of people
make mistakes but they're never really
held accountable for it but at least we
can laugh at them so at least we still
got that I was watching the FTX
commercial with Larry David have you
guys seen it no you know with all the
news on FTX going on I started like
digging into it and I watched the
commercial with Larry David and it's uh
basically it goes back to ancient times
as a guy with a wheel and Larry David
standing there is like what is it and
he's like it's a wheel he's like what
does it do when he's like it rolls and
he goes so does a bagel it's stupid then
it shows him like in with like a woman
and she's like pouring and she's like
it's coffee and you oh it's terrible and
like the gag was he was against all good
things and then one of the scenes is
he's with the founding fathers and then
they're like they have the Declaration
of Independence and he goes what do you
mean everyone gets to vote and they're
like yes everyone goes even the stupid
people and they're like yes he goes no
and he tries to rip up the Declaration
of Independence but uh that was the one
moment where I was like well I don't
agree with tearing up the Declaration of
Independence certainly but he brings up
a good point about stupid people voting
it is a problem and it needs to be
addressed somehow
no it absolutely is true it's true it's
gotten us here yeah maybe just has to go
back to the landowning men I'm sorry to
say I think it's when we started letting
women vote that things South well women
can own land the ladies that's right
yeah we have a sponsor that allows um
and you're you're a lady of Scotland
yeah and uh then you get to vote because
you own land what kind of property
rights do I have to it though honest
people allowed to trespass on my one
foot of land there probably probably not
I don't know you put my fence around it
yeah you could you could put a tree as
long as it doesn't grow that big it's a
square that actually would be really
cool to put a fence around it and like I
keep outside yeah we talked about this
before like do you get do you get the
air rights too like how high up and do
you get the mineral rights like you you
bring on a truck it just goes straight
down like three miles through your one
square foot you just have a Gatling gun
that shoots into the sky
yeah okay and about stupid people voting
it is a problem yeah what do you do you
know why I don't vote
that's a good right sure I get ahead of
it yeah
we could put Biden and fetterman in yeah
that's true I want to meet betterment
voters though I really do I want to meet
the people they actually just like him
I'm just imagining like going to the the
town he was mayor of and it's just
literally everyone looks like it's the
same it's all six foot five bald with a
bulge on their neck the women look like
him the men look like it yeah the same
radiation water has turned them all in
the same guy have you played Fallout 3
yes so you know the super mutants
they're all basically identical
that's true all right well people who
know the game are like that's very funny
right even the women Yeah so basically
in the game like the male and female
super mutants are just big Frankenstein
looking monsters yes that was incredible
yes that's the that's the better man
so uh what should we do Starship
Troopers service guarantee citizenship
IQ tests
I don't know look those can be wrong
and it's not so much about it like mine
was low I want to redo I don't think 40
it's low you can look I know people you
can open Tupperware I know people with
high IQs you give them a puzzle they'll
solve it you ask them did Joe Biden
engage in a quid pro quo they say no so
like IQ isn't really
no I'm not being serious about that but
I think it all comes down to the media
though it comes down to them talking
about like Mike Johnson is that what
you're driving
ligma and Johnson and that most people
aren't that stupid but it's what they're
being fed so I think they are that
stupid though
like that lady is that stupid like she
has to talk about it and just was like I
looked at that for two seconds and was
like yeah it's ligma and Johnson
and then she went into this piece on it
it never occurred her it's crazy no
she's like okay so lick my Johnson
should guys like go on like the other
guy might have known him was just Bobby
Suave we've had him on the show before
and I'm just like I don't understand why
didn't rob a and meet Robbie immediately
go like are you talking about Robbie
yeah
he's usually good too he might have done
it on purpose he's like he's like he's a
um he's of the libertarian sect that
somehow often is like pro-government I
guess that's such a weird yeah
bipolar way of life yeah that's enough
yeah yeah it doesn't make sense yeah I
don't know it's it's you know he often
has takes that are like in line with the
establishment and people are like what
are you talking about like you know but
I I think it's like whatever the
libertarian group was before the Muse's
caucus took over the mises guys are more
pragmatic before that I think they call
them like the pragmatist or something
and they're typically just like
I don't know libertarian even if it
supports an establishment narrative or
something can we make ligma Johnson a
lord yeah Lord buy it to make yeah wow
can we have lady ligma Johnson there you
go yeah
lady ligma and Lord Johnson yeah we
could have yeah Lord ligma Johnson and
Lady Lingus well I can only say right
now I'm pretty sure they're very happy
they sponsored the show because like
they're probably getting dozens of
orders for ligmont students they just
own a giant part of Scotland now
well that's the ligman Johnson Forest so
so there's
[Laughter]
right now there's 48 000 people watching
48 000 square feet of Lake Lord
Johnson owned land in Scotland no one
I'm not discouraging this at all I want
to see the land first I want to make
sure it's real first but other otherwise
you know there's there's a lot of other
candidates that we could go with you
know there's there's Willie stroker uh
there's uh Harry you know last name Cox
so we could keep going here uh but my
favorite thing one of my favorite things
was a skin was it was a skit by
Australian comedians that booked a
ticket
um and they booked it for a guy named
Terry last name wrist and and a second
passenger was called Al and then the
last name was Keda and they literally
missed their flight so over over the the
the speakers in the entire airport like
excuse me we're looking for a Terry
wrist and Mr Al-Qaeda to please go to
gate 14. you're about to miss your
flight Mr Terry risk and Al Qaeda please
come to Gate 14 you're about to miss
your it was a hilarious skit one way to
LaGuardia hilarious hilarious uh skit
idea by comedians there I forgot exactly
who the group was uh but they were they
were like absolute Geniuses they also
faked the motorcade
um so it would try to remember it would
be cool actually like even if you know
it wasn't the lordship thing that we
just got like 100 000 people to pitch in
10 bucks to buy a forest and create the
ligma Johnson Force I'm in we should do
it we should expect the ligma Johnson
foundation and have ligma Johnson
everywhere can we seriously can we save
an animal and then have like an ant
eater and it'll be the ligma Johnson
[Laughter]
okay we should set up a crowd fund I
mean just use the money to buy property
buildings donate to a hospital the ligma
Johnson wins
this is we're talking about stupid
people voting and we're sitting here
like who we're going to name stuff Luke
it would be great though for this one
too far
I agree I absolutely agree we gotta have
the small victories you know exactly
everything's doomed everything's
horrible and you know but but at least
we get to have ligma Johnson I
I will uh what if there's someone's
someone who actually is named ligma
Johnson and he's like listening to this
and he's just like guys this has been a
hard Road for me why don't we just why
don't we just start a new political
party right maybe maybe uh maybe we need
to make like some products
you know
an energy drink yeah look at my Johnsons
yeah like like my Johnson's uh underwear
I don't even be creative about it just
gas stations
um Dr ligma Johnson's Vitality formula
yeah
testosterone yeah and then we'll like
we'll put a fake thing on it where it's
like in 1803 Dr ligma Johnson created
this you know formula drink to
revitalize men yep and throw your hair
back and it'll give you a nice uh
package
it's an extension this is very important
news recovering today I guess I hope
everybody knows that this is all going
to be real this is exactly what they
covered though Tim they did this is the
news they cover and speaking of covers
condoms ligma Johnson oh that's not a
bad idea flavors
what's what's the what's the least
appropriate product we could make that's
like shouldn't be named ligma Johnson
ice cream
pacifiers ice cream yeah yeah
I was gonna say lollipop so man you take
it to another level Jesus that is a good
one though can we start a company called
ligma and Johnson and then just
basically whatever we name the product
it'll say under it you know ligma
Johnson yeah
you know and like it'll be like a
cursive l and a cursive J yeah parody on
Johnson and Johnson you're doing it sued
by Johnson and Johnson yeah we're just
uh it's a vaccine if you're like what's
it a four I don't know I I really like
the idea of like creating a forest
preserve and then people go on Google
and they zoom in like it's going to be
200 years later and there's going to be
some dude driving around with his wife
and they're like let's go to a park and
they pull up their map app in their
virtual space or whatever it is and
they're like oh ligma Johnson Lookout
and then they're gonna pull up and
they're gonna be like what a great View
and they're you know they're going to
look up on on whatever the future
Wikipedia is like the history of ligma
John it's like named because a bunch of
people on a podcast rallied a bunch of
people to take an internet meme about
looking someone's
genitals and turning it into a property
and they did but in the year like 3050
it'll be like the most quaint story
imaginable because everybody's just
garbage
I think a more practical idea
um I was gonna say something
inappropriate but but would actually be
maybe just uh a journalism award you get
the ligma Johnson journalism award for
actually getting things right and done
not being as ridiculous and dumb as ten
dollars oh that's a good point yeah I
like that exactly turn it yeah twist it
so so instead of standing for some you
know ignorant corporate media trash you
actually support rural journalism and
she has to present it to you
until the day she dies now what's the
statue going to be that's the real
question so it'll be kind of like a
rolling stone logo the ligma Johnson
Award for outstanding performance in the
field of Excellence yes I like that yeah
there you go and uh imperfection it
comes it comes with a ten thousand
dollar cash prize and the reason for
that is who would say no like you get up
on if you get up on stage and accept the
award and give a speech we will write
you a check congratulations I like it
and then that okay maybe a thousand
dollars I don't actually give them money
yeah so like a thousand dollars then a
percentage of that has to go to fund a
forest called ligma Johnson
how many bad journalists would be like
well I do want the money well you
probably have Brian Stelzer every year
no I mean he got fired so oh that's true
he's at Harvard yeah he's not a
journalist he's at Harvard yeah they
took him to Harvard I guess he teaches
class and how not to be gay in public
well they they they uh he teaches people
how to be bad at his job I guess yeah
it's kind of amazing that you can be
fired and get a job at Harvard it is
amazing yeah it's probably because you
know not good for whatever the world is
now
good for him I guess uh you're kind of a
Croc guy let's let's go back let's let's
go back to the Paul Pelosi thing because
I did have this story pulled out check
this out from the post-millennial body
cam footage shows Paul Pelosi opened the
door for cops contradicting Biden doj
quote two officers opened the door to
see the foyer of the Pelosi residents Mr
Pelosi wearing a long-sleeved shirt to
Pap in shorts running shoes and a
sweatshirt and a Pap and Mr Pelosi
jointly gripping a hammer okay wait what
Pelosi opens the door
and then walks over or something he
opened the door for the cops
so there you go reports emerged in the
body camera footage captured by police
that they went in and 42 year old depap
allegedly assaulted Paul blah blah blah
spoke with the source familiar with the
Pelosi investigation who personally
viewed body camera video recording of
officers and the body cam video shows
Paul Pelosi opened the door for police
despite the doj saying otherwise now why
would the doj lie about this now we did
cover this yesterday but the reason I
wanted to bring it back up is now we
have um
more people covering the story but we
also have this from The Daily Mail
suspended NBC News correspondent Miguel
almaguer breaks cover from his five
million dollar La home and hops in
Porsche to pick up flowers as
controversy controversy grows over his
report on Paul Pelosi's Hammer attack
yo how does this guy have a five million
dollar house and a Porsche
whoa
and anybody he looks uh we're in the
wrong business I think no we're in the
business what are you talking about
we're not chills though but but I mean
also it's important it's important to
note this guy hasn't tweeted since being
suspended so he hasn't publicly talked
about after he got in trouble for what
was clearly reporting on something that
actually did happen after of course
listening to police officers and
Reporting what police officers told to
him he was suspended after reporting on
uh yeah he got suspended he got he got
in trouble for reporting on the initial
claim that now NBC is reporting and
other news organizations are reporting
and now that there's allegedly uh you
know uh dash cam and police footage of
so so he told the truth and then he got
in trouble for doing so and now he has
to bring Paul Pelosi flowers yes maybe
that's what I'm thinking but but here's
here's my here's my point
how does this guy have enough money
for this like it's kind of crazy I'm
sorry I know I know the salaries of
journalists something here is weird
but he I mean
it right that's true his family's I mean
it is true that journalists come from
typically come from wealthy families
yeah could have money
could also maybe he invested well yeah
sure he could have gotten you know two
dollars a word for an article once and
really put that into fxt
sold just in time a five million dollar
house that's that's what do you think is
going on what's your I have no idea I
just think it's kind of weird the whole
story that's just garbage I mean
actually yeah for real though depending
on where you are yeah but uh you know in
Compton wow five million maybe but
probably not something really big in the
nicer areas two in the Hills I think uh
Hassan has a five million house in in
the LA area right what a good one that's
all socialist he is yeah well he
deserves it it's a nice area La gorgeous
here's a guy who now by all accounts
appears to have accurately reported some
weird goings-on with Paul Pelosi he gets
suspended
we don't know why they're not explaining
themselves the story is being
corroborated turns out it was likely
true the dude who reported it is
unnaturally wealthy I mean look if
you're a cop and you were investigating
something like this you'd be like how
does a guy who was like a journalist
afford all of these things sure I mean
maybe he comes from a rich family or
something like that I'm just
I just think it's kind of weird it was a
police investigate him for being wealthy
though I'm not I'm not saying him I'm
saying he likes to get improving system
if you're if you're if you're a doctor
and then and you and you're wearing gold
chains and living in a 10 million dollar
house what's wrong with that they're
going to be like them this guy doesn't
have that you know like something
doesn't add up here he's selling Oxys
for sure right no exactly they're going
to be like something's going on and so
I'm kind of like hey this is kind of
weird I don't trust these people
I think the big thing the whole thing's
a racket anyway you'd be surprised how
much money journalists do make to it you
know to a certain NBC too yeah but this
and who's his wife probably someone in
the White House oh there you go that
explains it I guess he drives a 134
000 car yeah has a five million dollar
gated a gated home in Studio City
California oh okay I don't know why
you'd want that I agree I was in that
area it just seems like a good way to
die hey that's literally where I'm
having like a really expensive housing
yeah yeah no no no I live in L.A for a
long time and it's just like yeah yeah
hey I mean I used to love it yeah it was
great 20 years ago yeah but not now no
it's not a tense yeah a lot of times
it's really sad really it's like there
used to be that little area that was
skid row and then it's just all the
greater now greater Skid Row yeah it's
so sad like it was that one block
downtown and then just now it's all of
downtown I know it's crazy did you guys
see uh Nancy Pelosi won her District it
was like 81 to like 19 or something
something like really yeah and it's
crazy to me because I'm like you'd think
the 12th time you stepped in human feces
you'd be like I'm not voting for the
president just in your driveway right
but but yeah there's like a video of a
woman taking a dump in the middle like a
middle like a residential street yeah
and people are like well there you go I
was in uh I was in LA and some woman
walked into the middle of the street and
this was not in a bad area and she just
pulls her pants off takes them off
squats in the middle of the street and
just lets it go and I was like oh that's
California for you this was this was
this is a while ago this was like seven
years ago where people clapping and
saying How brave she was yeah no people
were kind of running oh really yeah they
were like like not running running like
speed walking with like a little hustle
to get into the store to like get away
from it you know is she wearing a mask
no no this is way way before the
pandemic oh and there was a and then
like I'm walking and I was like oh well
you know there you go that's that's Los
Angeles and I look to my right and there
was just like maybe like seven or eight
morbidly obese homeless people and I
just thought to myself like man
we got fat homeless people we have fat
starving people in America isn't that
crazy are they really starving though
what do you mean by that malnutrition
yeah there's so much crap in their
bodies that they're actually starving
but they're morbidly obese at the same
time isn't that the majority of
Americans though yeah like every time I
look in the mirror friend 40 of
Americans I think are obese
I mean that's really got to be throttled
it's really bad yeah and it's only going
to get worse I'm looking at Miguel and
it looks like he he always was a career
journalist and it looks like he got the
money from NBC news from his career
there so they they probably have been
paying him a lot he's been working in
journalism since uh 2000 and I think the
main takeaway here is that he's been
very quiet he hasn't tweeted since being
suspended and the the fact that NBC News
retracted the official story here which
now is correct really is the big story
here really is very very telling here
because I think there's a reason
Miguel's not speaking out because he
could say hey I did my job I got the
story right I said it first and I think
it's it's maybe something similar to
what happened with ABC News and Amy uh
what's her name robishash roback roback
roback with project Veritas that exposed
her when she did a good story on Jeffrey
Epstein saying that she had Bill Clinton
she had all the politicians and and they
of course axed and deleted that story
and made sure that it never saw the day
of light there's probably something else
more Sinister here because again rich
people the most powerful people in the
world one have a bunch of security
around them so this whole story doesn't
make sense just on that
just one aspect of it but again as I
mentioned yesterday I'm sick of
speculating what happened here I'm just
going to imagine the worst possible
thing and they were sacrificing babies
and doing horrible things to them well
prove me wrong show me evidence
otherwise they were sacrificing babies
let's let's try this one on this story
about this uh almager guy if we're gonna
if we're gonna assume the worst then
it's NBC News pays this man an
exorbitant amount of money so that he
lies on TV
and then he doesn't question it because
he doesn't want to lose the big cash
that's called the job of an anchor
that's what they all get paid to do and
the other thing is he's got a five
million dollar home he might be staying
quiet because he knows that you know
especially since he's kind of Vindicated
now they might he might be able to sue
them for wrongful termination
he's suspended yeah but they're with pay
oh is he just suspended yeah look I'm
willing to bet they went to him and said
Hey look it's a bad time for this story
because the midterm's coming up so just
lie low for a bit and we'll give you a
bonus
yeah if you're making that kind of money
they're not just going to suspend you
and expect you not to say anything and
he's got to be getting money if he's not
tweeted I've told this story before how
I was like when I worked at fusion and I
said hey I don't want to be here anymore
and they were like well you're under
contract and I was like well this is
stupid and then a few months later they
gave me a call and they deposited tens
of thousands of dollars in my bank
account and then I was like yeah I still
don't want to be here and they're like
oh and then a few months later like okay
contract yourself you can leave and I
was like bye I mean the majority of
journalists I mean a lot of them have
substance abuse problems a lot of them
that I've that I've personally met and
hung out with especially I I one year I
got really hammered with the White House
Press Corps all of them depressed as
hell all of them are like yeah I just I
just got a family I I got bills to pay I
want to make sure that my kids go to a
good school they give me a script I read
it that's it and I think it's it's more
clearer by the day that they're just
doing the bidding of the special
interest of the powerful people of the
Pelosi's that at the end of the day
dictate what the people get to know
about because this story clearly
highlights how they covered up key facts
and evidence of what actually happened
here just to make themselves look better
just to cover up the truth from the
general public and until I see videos
until I see actual evidence there's no
reason to give the government and these
people the benefit of the doubt always
think the worst I you know I was
thinking because someone super chatted
about ligma Johnson
and I'm just thinking if we if we
started a political party yeah
like if that was on the ballot a lot of
people would be like yup and they might
for sure just meme a ligma Johnson
candidate into like the Libertarians
have been trying so hard to get a
candidate in Congress but if you put
ligma Johnson a lot of people are
probably going to be like it's it's a
protest to vote you know can we tell
Dave Smith to change his name legally
right now Dave you're listening to me
right now please I get 10 on this idea
change your name legally right now to
ligma Johnson I love Dave I would vote
for him in a heartbeat but if we do
ligma Johnson that man is going to be
president if he legally changes his name
to ligma Johnson and the American people
see it on The Ballot Box in 2024 there's
no doubt there's no doubt that American
people will go for it no no no I'll tell
you this with mail-in voting I guarantee
you if you go like so look what is it
you know 40 or 50 people don't vote Yes
you go to the door and you'll be like
hey did you vote you're like dude I
don't care about that yeah but you can
vote for ligma Johnson they're gonna be
like for real and be like yeah dude
Logan says lick my Jeff they're gonna be
like done that's the independent vote
that's
that's the vote of the Stoners that's
the vote of the Ian's that's the vote of
the loops everybody vote of the people
that's the populist working class right
there that's going to be like absolutely
we need this change dramatically I'm
sick of the two-party duopoly I'm sick
of the bidens the trumps I'm sick of all
that ligma Johnson 2024 I actually have
a shirt that says Lakewood Johnson 2024.
but that's a separate issue I I think
it's something that we could read Dave
Smith
seriously if you go to a football
tailgate to get those votes if any any
yes so many politics you could go you're
just getting high banners blips
everywhere ligma Johnson everywhere I
could see it remember remember when Deez
Nuts got all those votes yeah yeah see
yes Trump would have a meltdown too if
ligma Johnson actually sir that guy
legma Johnson don't know who he is
not a very nice name
not very nice at all
yeah but uh does it kind of does it does
it take away from you know if you were
to actually just get people to vote for
Dave Smith I guess it's idiocracy we
might as well meet people where they're
at right we might as well just go there
why not right what else are we going to
do okay well you know I couldn't help
but bring the ligma Johnson thing again
because it's just more interesting but
we have the story from post-millennial
this is just happening now breaking news
Twitter temporarily closes office
building suspends employee access on
Thursday it was revealed that Twitter
had temporarily closed its Office
Buildings and suspended access badges
the officers officers are expected to
reopen Monday November 21st giving Elon
Musk and his team a chance to sort
things out sort what out
no details as given why they just
basically shut down we're hearing this
is because Elon Musk and his team are
terrified employees are going to
sabotage the company also they're still
trying to figure out which Twitter
workers they need to cut access for
shifter report that employees were being
told to continue to comply with company
policy by refraining from discussing
confidential company information on
social media with the press or elsewhere
it's interesting Elon Musk effectively
performed a hostile takeover of a woke
institution yes these these people are
whiny baby children and are imploding
and this is what happens when you do
it's it's
fascinating it's imagine like you're on
the high seas and you board the enemy
ship
they're not just gonna be like well I
guess we work for you now well it was
like this comical employment where
you're getting insane amounts of money
you're you know riding a scooter through
the office it's just this insane job
that you could have and now they don't
know what to do there's no like it's not
even realistic I mean that's what our
headquarters is basically like a daycare
have you seen the video in the day in
the life of a Twitter employee and they
have meditation rooms and game rooms and
lattes and whatever wine bars yeah on a
roof yeah yeah yes they're these little
latte liberals who are like basically
working in a giant daycare and they're
go they have they're going online and
complaining about their boss and then
being like why did I get fired he's this
big evil man
um but he wouldn't have done anything if
they weren't complaining about him
publicly yeah Patrick Bateman in the 80s
would seem like a harder worker than
anybody on Twitter maybe what needs to
happen is Elon just buy all the
companies
and then I'll just crumble oh that would
be great grab Facebook
I would love it I would like it yeah on
its own it's falling apart yeah they are
doing it great they just did a massive
layoff too didn't they what was it 10
000 employees they're laying off yeah
but
Zuckerberg was right to try something
new with meta yeah AR stuff because
Facebook itself as a company is aging
out of existence yep that's it they're
going AOL that's what everyone thought
was gonna happen good good riddance get
out of here I'm sick of your crap yeah
but Tick Tock is replacing them yeah but
at the same time okay fine but but that
Empire was absolutely evil with how they
worked and orchestrated larger psyopsis
against than American people how they
censored people I I think we are seeing
a digital uh transition I I think what
we're seeing at Twitter is some kind of
Civil War happening inside of that
company obviously I would not want to be
at the helm of being in charge of
thousands of woke employees project
Veritas did an undercover video one of
the employees at Twitter said that they
worked four hours a week okay imagine
having to deal with those kind of
entitled individuals that just want to
be at a wine bar the whole time it it
would be extremely difficult to get
anything done here I I'm still waiting
for Elon Musk to bring people back back
that were banned but I could see a lot
of internal battles a lot of internal
fights happening right now just
basically on that one particular issue
the unbannings I think this is
personally just from my own speculation
what this is all about and there's
probably some people at the at the
company saying I'll uh I will jeopardize
this I will expose this I will say this
I will destroy this company I will tell
people how many Bots are on this company
if you allow Donald Trump to be on this
platform or project Veritas or all the
other dozens of individuals or Babylon b
or everyone else that that should have
not been banned do it the issue is the
advertisers though he's really
struggling with trying not to bankrupt
this company by you know throwing all
the advertisers to the wind I think
that's why he was so quick to try the
Twitter blue stuff too which obviously
was rolled out a little too quickly
um I think he knew that yeah he did but
um so I think that's why we're not
seeing a lot of these unbannings yet is
because he's trying to really grapple
with him why he's getting rid of some of
the staff as he needs it on the right
track to tell advertisers hey this is
you know where we need to go this is
probably why he didn't want to buy it he
tried backing out he saw the data and
then realized that the reason Twitter is
doing this is because of Advertiser
pressure and that if he goes in and
makes these changes then the advertisers
drop there's no money and the company's
gone and so they were like good luck
buddy but that's why as soon as he comes
in like you said Twitter blue right now
everyone sign up or government pressure
I already did
you signed up yeah I did but he needs to
implement a class structure there
because I bought Twitter blue and my
check mark my check mark used to saying
this person's verified because she's
really cool and super important and now
it says it's because I pay for Twitter
Flume yeah it's fine everybody can know
Elon says that too he made he made a
mistake with that one because right now
he he is saying he's going to remove
Legacy Badges and they're all they're
going to drop off the next couple of
months fine but bro if you're if you're
if you're going around saying like you
can have the limited edition first
edition badge or the like like the
reprint I don't want to reprint no no
like why am I going to pay for that okay
and Tim you know the dimensions are
really bad Luke you know that it's
really hard for us to sort things not to
be in elitist Twitter prick but it's
really bad you know I can't see you know
you can't see anything that's notable or
there's so many people attention it's
really I only talk to important people
that's what you're saying so let me tell
you it's hard to you know when you use
it for business too it's hard to sort
through Dimensions now it's going to my
my mobile app is the Twitter Beta app
which I've not updated
yes and um my mentions are the same as
they've always been
anyone who bought Twitter blue does not
appear verified on this app really yeah
so I I noticed because we got Twitter
blue for timcast news because I was like
I want the news organization to have a
verification badge on it and so I logged
on my phone and there's no badge and I
was like what I was like what am I what
am I paying for and then I looked online
and it was there and I was like huh then
everyone started saying mentions were
busted and I pulled up my phone and
looked and I'm like the only people in
my mentions are Legacy verified people
and so uh so you're not updating I'm not
updating
no see Tim he's an elitist prick too
well so he's earned it but this is
interesting
I already have a mentioned sections a
section for everyone
if you tweet at me and you're talking at
me and you have and you you have a
standard count that's fine the
verification tab doesn't doesn't need to
be the the elites or anything like that
but it does create a space where the
people who are interacting with me are
working for some company or something
like that right so then it's typically
what typically what I see is journalists
talking about stuff or people I know and
have worked with talking about stuff
now with the Twitter blue verification
I'm hearing people say like they lost
that feed of their colleagues yep so
he's got to figure out filters for this
stuff yeah but I again I think he rolled
it out so quickly that because he just
wanted to give a cushion to everything
that's going on with the advertisers but
I don't really think there's a way
around that
um he's just got to let go that the
advertisers they're not going to care if
he lets these people back on the
platform they're the advertisers are
gone well what I don't like is that he
created the second verification
the official tag now like wow dude so
it's confusing and weird and right and
why does the corporate media right it
just and how so how do I get it for Tim
cast news huh I want you know I want to
be double verified what do I got to do
huh we are changing with Johnson yeah
huh how are we gonna make sure he gets
into office with this kind of
shenanigans I know you know what's going
on here not to mention two with a lot of
the people though that the age that
we're working for them the fact that
that's kind of the mentality of that
group does he is there a way that he can
actually control his employees I mean
how do you really know I mean aren't
they kind of old against him mine is a
small percentage you know I'll I'll tell
you that I don't know
the challenges is best described this
way if you have a storefront in any City
and uh it's not on here and you put a
sign in the window that says you support
Trump in the middle of the night a guy
puts on a mask and throws a brick
through your window causing you
thousands of dollars in Damages and
potentially shutting your store down for
the day you call the police what are the
police going to tell you oh you have
insurance yeah they said well what are
we supposed to do about it you say I
don't know stop the guy how I got video
footage of him okay it's a guy in a
hoodie what do you want us to do
forensic analysis CSI dust for Prince
track every server it's not going to
happen
so Elon Musk knows this
if someone does sabotage the company
sure he can look in the logs but I I
would guarantee you
that if one of his employees committed a
felony against him law enforcement would
do nothing about it
it's probably true
establishment we would have to use his
own people to actually press charges
against him and go that route that would
never it'll never happen you don't think
so absolutely not if uh if it was the
other way around yeah hands down oh of
course if Twitter was owned by You Know
Jack Dorsey and Vijaya got it at the
helm and it was pro-democrat like it had
been for years oh for sure and an
employee sabotaged it because they were
tied to the political bias they'd be
locked up in 10 seconds oh I agree and
and I'm not saying this based on like
perceived political bias I'm saying it
based on actually looking at how law
enforcements and operating in this
country and uh personal experience if if
someone commits a very serious federal
crime it will not it just doesn't happen
like
I've talked a lot like swatting is a
really great example I was just going to
bring that up but I didn't know if we
were supposed to go right exactly I'm
going to say that specifically what you
were mentioning partly yeah but um we
have evidence
and so you know I go we've talked to
multiple law enforcement agencies and
they're just like guy you have you have
you you have armed guards you're fine
and then I'm like dude this is like gone
on too much they're committing crimes
they're like don't care sorry have a
nice day it's nothing it's been a year
yeah they're using your people to commit
crimes and you don't care
but but the issue is now that we are
paying for it right now that we pay for
uh armed guards and things like that
they're like oh so we don't worry about
anymore right
so so what
and I'm like okay they don't care in
general though because I know I had a
really bad stalker Lauren Southern and I
had the same stalker I stopped it was it
was very you're here I know well
it was really bad and I remember you
know it got escalated up to the FBI and
I had the FBI he was the head of the
Cyber crimes Division and he calls me
and I said yeah a lot of this stuff is
happening on Twitter the guys made like
300 plus YouTube videos about me
um you know what the guy at the FBI the
head of the cyber crime division you
know what he told me he said have you
tried calling Twitter I said start with
alter perspective you think I can call
Twitter you shouldn't be headed cyber
crimes unit seriously to call Twitter
about a stalker a very serious stalker I
had the FBI that's amazing well you know
if if there's a if there's a track if
there's a traffic violation the cops are
there and it generates revenue for the
state but uh your life's in danger they
don't give a damn that's that's usually
the protocol of what's Happening Here
and it's very interesting to to see
what's happening because we have U.S
senators right now calling for the FTC
to investigate Twitter and Elon Musk as
we have the whole FTX scandal with
clients losing billions of dollars and
then they don't care about that they're
they're not really doing anything around
that issue the FBI is giving a warning
to the guy saying hey we probably will
be investigating you this is your time
to leave and Escape right now literally
giving away warning it's almost like
they laundered 40 million dollars for
the Democrats well that's what it looks
like absolutely the crazy thing about
FTX is it seems like what they were
trying to do what this guy bankman Frida
sang is hey we didn't do anything on
tour with your money we didn't gamble it
we we loaned it to Alameda yeah and then
alameda's Investments and they make
investments their money they weren't
gambling that's what their company does
and the money's lost yep my question
where was the money invested who
benefited because think about the the
chain right here Democrats 11 billion
people
11 oh I'm sorry 11 billion dollars
obviously not a billion people 11
billion dollars in American uh money was
was in FTX gone now because it's
transferred to Alameda Alameda did
something with that money
they didn't give 11 billion dollars to
Democrats
and why does it stop there why where why
is the media just stopping here let's
figure out where Alameda put that money
because I'm willing to bet there's
there's more co-conspirators
so they basically are playing this game
of look I'm just a company that that
received that invests in uh this that or
otherwise and Alameda came to me and
said they wanted to invest don't look at
me the money's mine now it's clean how
many steps until they actually take that
money and doesn't come back
yeah it's like the cartel
essentially well it is it's the same
thing it's money laundering I mean it's
just it's so what do you do with cocaine
it's what you do with anything else 40
million of it went to Democrats yes 40
million went to democrats for uh ballot
harvesting yeah largely
the U.S taxpayer dollars essentially
yeah and then you have these huge names
that had a huge amount of money in you
know involved in it so it's out there
it's completely public I think there's
also breaking news right now of the
local government in in the Bahamas
actually taking control of the remaining
FTX assets uh right now in the making of
this video so they also invested a lot
of money in alleged Tech startups in
allegedly global warming and also
fighting the next pandemic where that
money went I think you know we should be
asking a lot of very serious questions
because people were defrauded people
lost their money that money of course
was was sent to politicians not just
Democrats also you know GOP causes and
Republican candidates as well and
they're Super PAC so we have to
understand you know protection money
goes both ways how will it protect them
what's going to happen next is going to
be really really interesting and
fascinating to see how rotten and
corrupted the entire system is yeah
you're right everything they did say
that they spent the money on was this
very very just sort of uh yeah very
generalized topics they were they were
quicker to stop redditor who were
investing in GameStop and AMC oh very
quick absolutely very quickly yeah yeah
that was that was a National Emergency
they got they got the agents ready for
those do not pass go do not collect I
just had GameStop because I knew a
PlayStation was coming out and I was
like I don't know maybe and then one day
I was like oh wow
I'm rich look at that so apparently this
report from Daily Mail Bahamas
government ordered Fallen crypto CEO Sam
bankman free to hack FTX systems and
transfer assets to the island nation
after he filed bankruptcy
wow well then but what are we doing
about this what is the FTC doing about
this they just find Kim Kardashian a
million dollars for not putting like
hashtag ad on her Instagram post or not
just closing how much she made on an
Instagram post they're gonna investigate
Twitter you know because Elon Musk is
bringing in ligma Johnson yeah we can't
have that yeah that's a big problem that
guy is going to change the world
you know what people are saying in the
Bahamas some rich people bankman free is
going to get away with it to a great
degree because he paid freed he paid for
it he bought his immunity and so the the
Press is he's getting scrutiny because
of Twitter he's getting screwed because
of Reddit he's he's not having these
these hardcore journalistic exposes
coming out in fact I think uh I think if
we have this tweet here we go look at
this Jake Shields tweeting looks like
this event uh look this looks like an
event not to miss zelenski bankman freed
Larry Fink and many more including Janet
Yellen the New York Times event November
30th 8 A.M to 6 p.m only twenty four
hundred dollars to attend yeah if you
look at the partners of he who he was
working with he was working with the
Ukrainian Bank he was working with the
world economic Forum he was working with
Tony Blair he was working with Bill
Clinton he's he's working with known
people who are uh war criminals and uh
child diddlers let's be honest here he
was working with the worst of the worst
when it comes to the most powerful the
most evilest people on the Facebook of
this Earth so I think it's fair to
conclude especially with how fast the
company was was was made so popular
especially with everyone on the
corporate media Shilling for him calling
him the next JP Morgan and Chase that
there's something up here that's a lot
more nefarious than we actually know
about I think right now we only know
very little about what actually happened
here I think a lot of this was maybe a
money laundering front I think there was
a lot of secret shadowy money moving
around coming from one place going to
another place I think what what is what
could be potentially uncovered here is
some deep down intelligence agency
connected psyops and extortion rackets
that that could probably blow people's
minds away but again that's just
speculation but at the end of the day
right now what else are we left to think
here did you guys see that uh I think it
was a lensky who said it was a Russian
missile and NATO's wrong yep
world war three yeah he's like I imagine
that you know he does these videos where
he's like we must protect freedom and
Russia as a terrorist State then as soon
as the camera turns off he just goes
because this dude's out of his mind no I
feel like he just ordered some of the
same hookers as Hunter has a good time
he closes the laptop and then Hunter
walks out and then he's like smoking
crackpipe and he's like good job let's
do this yeah they're on the same yacht
yeah it's not illegal because we're on
the water yeah
he is one of my favorite Babylon B
headlines that we did after what was it
hurricane Ian um that awful it said uh
president zielinski is on a wrap asking
hurricaneian victims for money for
Ukraine
well they know they need their money I
guess yeah
I feel like is this just something that
they're doing because there's no actual
real money so now they're just creating
money to kind of get more legitimate
money back into the
more real money does that make sense
There's real money well no there's not
real money but there's money that we
think is more real than other money it's
War it's War that's war war was it good
for increasing domestic Manufacturing in
March of 2020 we got off the fractional
Reserve uh system and switched to the
infinite Reserve System meaning Banks
could create Money On Demand with with
no restriction at all and print money
and then the IRS that takes your fake
money yeah well so the point of the IRS
is to limit Financial expansion and
inflation yes not to actually fund the
government right because modern monetary
Theory so what happens is
when a bank when you take your credit
card and swipe that money is created
yeah and that you know when a bank gives
out a loan the money is created they're
not giving you money they have and since
March of 2020 they've had no
restrictions it used to be it was like a
90 restriction so if they had 100 Grand
they could create 90 more and then what
people are complaining about is that you
create that money and put it another
bank that bank then loans at another 90
which then puts into another bank and
then they keep doing that and eventually
they were like this is dumb let's just
tell the banks they can make money
endlessly and now the money supply is
through the roof people are just
printing making it I kind of feel like
in 2008 they knew the system was
collapsing so they started preparing to
jump ship and they were like let's print
as much money as possible for ourselves
to absorb as much natural resources that
we can and enrich ourselves that when
the system collapses will be the Lords
of our little fiefdoms oh I knew in 2008
it was going to end when the dumbest
cokeheads I knew were driving sixty
thousand dollar cars and selling three
million dollar houses seriously good for
them huh well I mean not really I think
they spent it all pretty quick yeah
and here we are but it was yeah it all
worked out though I guess my advice is
uh get a nice little plot of land and
get some chickens some goats or Forest
I'm not gonna get about this like my
Johnson forces yeah we could pull this
we could pull this off we can't be in
this I mean I can I can name the forest
on free Namaste and the ligma Johnson
Forest right now
it's like 30 Acres of forested area we
have to make this a public place though
that people could come into and enjoy
ligma Johnson's in the fullest extreme
the family yo exactly hold on there's
like 200 acres of forested land for like
a million bucks
so all we need is a hundred thousand
people to donate ten dollars and then we
will have a public
land was it they got 20 on it right now
make it 15 and we can put bathrooms and
then you know ligma Johnson we could
adopt a highway too
it's just gonna be a town at this point
I don't know do you think that we like I
so I know where there's a big plot of
land like 200 acres for like a million
bucks and it's forested all forested
there's a road going through it and it's
it's weirdly shaped but uh
you know if we if we got
if we got uh 50 000 people to give 20
bucks
you know can we make Dave mayor of ligma
Johnson please
yes thank you we'll build a statue
because you be the Lord
no no no no it's you you will build a
statue of you right when you come in
it'll be like welcome to ligma Johnson
you know amen look forward that's the
two pranksters the two ogs need to be
recognized that's true so it'll be it'll
be a statue of Dave as like a jolly old
man with his arm around the ligma
Johnson guys yeah cigar in his mouth
they'll be right in there but the ligma
Johnson guys have to be huge like yeah I
could be power I could be in the middle
of them but smaller I'm fine with that I
know where I stand
and then the woman who was on there
reporting the story she's just in a
glass box crying the whole time yes the
real woman we'll we'll put a statue of
her and we'll do like they do these
things out here because it's all Civil
War territory yes where they have these
like placards that are covered and you
can read about the history we'll do that
as you walk the trail the ligma Johnson
Forest explaining like it won't just
talk about ligma Johnson it will talk
about the history of the corrupt media
yes this would actually be really cool
but you'd need an extra like 10 grand
for something like that for installation
and stuff but it would be really cool if
you like walked the path and they were
like little things being like you know
in this year this you know media
organization lied about this and stuff
like that you followed the years back to
the origin of fake news and it's you
know talking about like fake reports
like when uh who was it who was it who
reported that Napoleon had won then the
stocks crashed oh the Rothschilds is
that that the Rothschild did that they
had they had someone claim that the
Napoleon won the Napoleonic Wars and
then also the stocks were collapsing
started buying them all by crazy and
then the real world came real word came
in that he actually lost and then all of
a sudden everything that was worth way
more yeah you know so there you go like
go back to the origins of the fake news
narrative manipulation stuff all the way
to like Marilyn Monroe who's just not
oding it's just two CIA agents
MK Ultra yeah that'd be super cool you
know we do let's we buy the land and
then we let the public put up whatever
placard they want because like just shut
up and do it whatever it's public land
have fun I mean and like there'll be one
big sign of the entrance being Like You
by entering this property you can't sue
us and then at the end it says Biden
fetterman 2021 it's a no-brainer damn
right we all win we got to take back the
comments I I kind of think this is
possible this would be like a huge thing
if we were able to do it start a crowd
fund you need to raise a little bit more
for closing costs and stuff like that
find the plot of land announce that we
want to buy it and then see if people
are willing to pitch in 10 bucks to buy
the land and we'll put it into a trust
or something or like maybe we make it
available to the general public and we
make it a big Park she make it a
scholarship for journalists the ligma
Johnson Scholars yeah but I want to give
those people money you know what I mean
like I don't want to put people in
Germany yeah you don't want to you don't
want them go to it they could be
actionation camps big theme park
so that would be a lot harder but you
want to be open to you know it's like 50
years later we're all old and that's
like the happiest place on Earth Park
ligma Johnson
it's like Disney but you're always
Dave's there and he's very old and
they're like tell us the story again
Dave about how this was around well kids
it was 50 years I couldn't stop talking
about it yes the pacifiers I just bring
it back and the condoms what if what if
like
what if we like pitch this to Elon and
asked him to contribute because look the
real goal is no one's going to own this
it's going to be like a privately owned
public space in a trust so the value is
retained with the property but you
create a public park and you call it
ligma Johnson and it would just uh you
know maybe I'm pretty sure we could find
some rich people who get down on that
for sure all right all right let's let's
do it I have some people who didn't lose
to the X they got to be out there that's
right let me let me write down ligma
Johnson I'm writing it down no he's
serious I'm serious yeah he's real
serious um and uh does anybody have
elon's phone number I do you do yeah
well I call Twitter
I will call Twitter after the show and
then um
here's an idea
we could uh somehow use the property as
a way to uh help support Twitter and
then everyone when they log in they just
see the fundraiser on the top of their
feeds powered by ligma Johnson that's
right that's right
what if he what if what if Elon changes
the verification badge to the ligma
Johnson badge oh what does our badge
look like though just balls
just a nice set well like here's here's
what I'm thinking to what degree could
Elon screw with Twitter and we'd all
just go along with it you know like
already we have double oh I will I would
ride it he could burn it down that'd be
great I know I'm I'm sitting here it
would be like 2015 Twitter all over
again fire everybody and just hire
people over the age of 45.
yeah I mean why doesn't he just strip
everything out of it and turn it into a
decentralized text feed and just be like
we got no staff protocol nobody's in
charge of it yep just protocol there you
go it'll look just forever people will
use it and nobody makes money on it yep
he lose 44 billion dollars I guess and
his investors would be really really
angry he's got to pay that debt back so
I don't know yeah he but he wants to
make it WeChat he wants to make it that
we have to do almost everything on there
so I don't think that's the vision right
he uh sees with Twitter I gotta be
honest if it were me like I would roll
out a ligma Johnson button yeah on on
the left just because because you need
to you know yeah well it's like a like
button but better yeah and every you
know you could ligma the post yeah what
does a ligma mean what does the ligma
mean is it a gun is that like a lion
it's like a light oh yeah you click it
it's it's it well it's you know the like
implies you like it or you're favoriting
it right now the just means you're
ligament it that's it yeah I don't know
what it means it's whatever it means to
you yeah exactly
just think about
the ability to do funny stuff like that
you know what I mean like I yeah I don't
know like that as well you you think you
think you you think I'm not being
serious let me no I think you're being
serious nothing's funny anymore because
everything's so crazy well everything
you say is just under a microscope and
being attacked I'm telling you right now
if you go to timcast.com and you go to
the join us page you can see uh you want
to pull that up you can see we've got
our rooster Roberto Jr and our cat bocus
in our talent tree and of course Jamie
kilstein Jamie you're still there
despite the fact that Jamie was
Consulting and now he's not here right
now but uh I put my rooster Roberto Jr
up in our really good headshots your
rooster and your cat it is very good
bocus how does the star of the show how
did you get them is it a male rooster is
that your male rooster is there a female
rooster Luke is there is there is there
such thing as a female it's it's 20 22.
Chicken on there that is my male chicken
I like it I also put a 96 foot tall
billboard of him in Times Square
oh did you really oh yeah you did I saw
that that's a 96 foot tall picture of my
[ __ ] was up in Times Square family
friendly show here yeah yeah
what do you think we're talking come on
come on you know that's my point I'm
just like I don't know I don't know
exactly what it did but it was something
you know I'm just waiting for Elon to
throw up high I guess he kind of is
though the ligma Johnson stuff I'm I'm
I'm I'm all for it someone's got to do
something it's getting boring yeah
that's the positive thing about Trump
you know that's why people love Trump
people were so bored and tired and they
wanted someone to you know yep
and that's what we enjoyed seeing he
still is he very clearly still is that's
why everyone's so upset about uh him
running again yes
and the meltdowns are pretty fun yeah
just to watch people lose their minds
it's fun to see the Republicans melting
down over him again yeah that was fun
I'm like he has 2015 all over again I'm
like yeah same people I love DeSantis
but the DeSantis Bros are coming out in
full force right now and they're so
annoying they're so cringe I think a lot
of people take themselves too seriously
yeah I think that's the main issue a lot
of people are like Angry how dare you
trigger or get angry at Trump and I'm
like well just just stop it stop with
the nonsense same with the DeSantis does
Santa says it even announce he's not
even running and you got these guys like
saying no it's going to be to Santa's
the guy's not even running right now no
his exact yeah his exact words where I
just won this election could you calm
down and let me do my job you know so
you know we could try to do and I mean
it we could we could set up a fundraiser
uh a a crowd fund none of the money we
would set up a bank account with like a
trust or something
um we got to figure out the proper legal
way to do it maybe we actually have all
the money go specifically to like a
lawyer or something so that no one no
individual benefits from it and the
lawyer is only signed like ability is to
transfer the money for the property or
something
and then uh I I bet if we got a bunch of
other prominent personalities
um commentators on board with it we
could easily raise money to buy a large
plot I bet you could make it a 501c3 too
very difficult to do take two years two
years later we'll be having a committee
meeting to determine how we move forward
so you know a lot of people ask like
what we're doing with our fact checking
organization yeah we've been in filing
for a year and a half so uh maybe uh
after 27 months when all of that gets
confirmed we'll actually be able to do
something but that's how it goes there
there are things you can do but but you
know maybe a trust for it or something
like that maybe there's like a public
trust thing you can do I don't know
maybe you can make it so that after a
hundred years the the property reverts
to the local jurisdiction you know but
it can't ever have its name changed
something like that but I I we don't
even got to do a million dollar property
we could probably find 50 acres
and get something for just a forested 50
acres find something in eastern West
Virginia I bet you could find 50 acres
for like 100 or 200 Grand they like give
away land in Kansas though you could
probably get cheaper there's parts
that's true right you can just have
like a dollar
we should do that yeah buy a whole
neighborhood I feel like it would be
even better if it's in Detroit what if
what if we went into an area where there
was at least 100 people
and then bought up enough property to
Lobby those people to create a new city
a Township inside of it well because uh
I think you need like a hundred people
to incorporate a town or something I'm
in the city of ligma Johnson
time before it already I already know
some properties but you know you know
the thing about buying by forested areas
that you really can make it just like a
park and like people can come hang out
well in Detroit though you have pit
bulls and gangs of them roving around so
really yeah of course wow yeah it's been
that way forever are you allowed to have
guns yeah oh okay I don't think I mean
if you're allowed to or not you can buy
one out of a paper bag I don't know if
it works but they are around
oh man what a sad story Detroit yeah it
was once called the Paris of the Midwest
really yeah yeah yeah they called it
that yeah now it looks like someone
dropped the nuke on it well yes well if
that happened in the late 60s and it's
just sort of stayed the same the
downtown's looking nice that's what
everyone yes it is it's improving yeah
it's great yeah it's nice down there
well I wouldn't say it's improving it's
a City built for seven million people
with 700 000 living in it so right lots
of property we could buy for a town
infrastructure is really expensive
though because of that it's like 10
times the cost for water and stuff yeah
the taxes are very pricey yeah yeah
that's why I'm saying West Virginia
baseballs were out here yeah and I've
already seen property maybe like an hour
west of where we're at where it's like
there's a river that's nice and and some
of them even have like power conduit
like power conduits or whatever so you
call the electric company and then
they'll just put a meter and plug the
power on but I think they're actually in
a frozen homeless guy in An Elevator
Shaft that's been abandoned for years
and we can have that you're saying again
well now I'm sold I'm just trying the
ligma Johnson Elevator Shaft and then
what we'll do is we'll immortalize the
Frozen homeless man with the statue at
the bottom of the chef and maybe he'll
come to life like Encino Man okay except
it'll just be not fun to hang out with
them we can have a shaft cam I'm
watching all that stuff you know what's
funny
what if we do this what if we crowdfund
what if we crowdfund a city
okay I'm for it we we buy the property
and then basically open it up to whoever
wants to build on it to build on it like
there would have to be an approval
process obviously yes because we're
going to allocate land but someone could
be like I want to have my own store and
it's be like the land is yours like we
lease the land on on the property to
your store so long as you maintain it
we'll do rules like if at any point you
give up the store for longer than a year
then the property opens up and we can
lease it out to somebody else but the
goal is not for people to own ligma
Johnson it's to create a crowd-funded
city I feel a crowd-sourced city yeah so
they can just come they don't have to
pay and they can oh it's like Johnson
they're the ideas yes my idea is this if
we get the property and you come to me
and say I want to open a gun store we'll
say where right there how much space do
you need I need one acre signed one acre
for this amount of time if you abandon
the shop then you give us the right to
lease the property to somebody else so
we can keep it going but you're not
we're not taking money for it we're just
basically like okay first come first
serve we're gonna crowdsource that's
what they did in L.A let's get wrong oh
first come the first sir yeah but with
it being in the middle of nowhere you're
not going to get derelict individuals
because there's no easy there's no stuff
they're not going to walk them no one's
gonna walk like it's here in the middle
of the woods no what you're going to
find is like a dude who's got time and
some spare materials who's like I could
put together a little shop that'll be
cool and then when people come here they
can buy Gatorade from me like I'm down
like and we're not going to take any
money for it it's like you do your thing
like if you're like I want to set up a
turquoise jewelry shop we'll just kill
you
we'll let them set up their turquoise
jewelry and then we'll burn its own no
no see this lady is like crying she'll
look like hey I'm the mayor I'd be like
yeah lady who looks like the the old guy
in thinner
I think uh I think trying to crowdsource
a village would be fun I would do it
doctor shows up and he's like I'll put
up a little like first aid medical thing
it's like have fun
all you really all you really need is
someone to try and organize to make sure
people aren't overlapping with each
other and you know stepping each other's
toes yeah we can't have the gun shop in
the same well yeah we could well this is
a liquor store yeah you want to do
Anarchy Style just let people build
whatever they want where they want yeah
I mean there's an amazing campsite
um that pork fest usually happens every
year uh at the Rogers campground that's
for sale so we could buy the campgrounds
and call it the lakema Johnson
campgrounds
right the ligma Johnson campgrounds yeah
and pork fest once a year yeah what
podcast what's here with the Free State
why wouldn't we yeah if we didn't all
right we're gonna go to super chats
uh if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
we're gonna have a very fun unfamily
friendly members only show coming up at
11 PM you don't want to miss it let's
see what we got here
all right what's this
cam says nice to see Dave back let's get
rid of the demon babies and when are you
coming back to Raleigh for stand up
can't wait great guest as always Tim
oh thank you uh I don't know when I'm
gonna come back to really I'm actually
gonna I'm working on it though because
I'm gonna do another album with helium
and uh actually I'm gonna do special I
can bring that up real quick uh at The
Comedy Castle uh in December in Detroit
or uh in Detroit actually we just talked
about it where it'll be the uh eighth
and 9th of December come out to that and
uh but yeah to be back in Raleigh I
should be there probably like middle of
next year so come out and thank you very
much and Herschel should be getting rid
of the demon baby soon all right it's
his main part of his his secret class
yeah yeah I heard he wants to be a
werewolf now he does he's like that's
pretty cool yeah you know the vampire
yeah yeah because because werewolves can
kill vampires I guess so you know yeah
yeah I'd vote for a werewolf is that
Twilight I mean look herschel's here
campaign and I don't see any vampires no
that's a good point yeah if he goes away
Herschel could be blade stay safe
all right all right
let's see uh Delio Turk says they said
it repeatedly they're going after Joe
well good you know
Steph D says I want to know who bought
Hunter's artwork for 500K
somebody who is funneling money to
Hunter Biden probably FTX it was the big
guy yeah right yep you can get like a
Val Kilmer painting for 250 dollars yeah
I did yeah did you stinky Wizzle tweet
teets says you have to admit that the
green m m is pretty sexy even after they
gave her less sexy shoes
I really like Freedom Tunes making fun
of uh tuck tuck Tucker Carlson
that was really good and if you saw it
his Sheamus's Tucker voice they're
making the green m m less sexy no why
would they do that Bernie Sanders comes
in and he's like I am so pissed off
the green Eminem then Ben Shapiro comes
in that was a good one Sheamus
what have we here
Trident 54 says lord Timothy do you
think it's possible that the GOP
Senators can convince 17 Progressive
Senators to put identity politics above
party convict Joe Biden and place the
first woman of color in the Oval Office
oh Perhaps Perhaps well I think it's
more likely they are the amendment 25
him you know I'm with you yeah they come
out and say look guys Biden's brain is
broken Kamala Harris first woman of
color to be president let's roll or
Kamal Harris is an insurrectionist
because she funded terrorists um during
the 529 Insurrection and she's in and
out and she's ineligible so she can't
run for re-election and uh Joe Biden's
campaign staff actually did too so
they're both
um they're they're both disqualified so
you know well there you go I feel like
they're saving the first woman of color
president slot for Michelle Obama though
you think she'll run uh if they were
smart they would run Michelle Obama yeah
yeah I think Joe Rogan was saying that
too right yeah he was and that's if they
were doing that and I just saw she did
an interview where she was coming out uh
saying you know it was a real shame that
she had to put her career on hold while
uh good old Barry was in the Oval Office
Josh Butler says please have Sheamus
make a tune with Biden and fetterman
having a basic conversation
well I can't make shamans do anything
but Sheamus if you're listening a
cartoon where Biden and fettermen are
having a conversation
there's a meme
that exists that I shared that's
absolutely hilarious it's the two of
them looking at each other and it's uh I
can't even say what they said on here
but okay
all right what have we here
my third nut says hey Dave love seeing
you here and and on crowder also excited
to see your show tomorrow you've got a
show tomorrow yes uh Friday and Saturday
I will be in uh Virginia at uh Richmond
Virginia at the Funny Bone cool I'm
sorry my fly my flight landed at 4am it
was very delayed and now I'm just brain
dead but yeah I'll be in Richmond
Virginia at the Funny Bone oh cool it's
fun too far from here yeah we should go
tomorrow what time well maybe Saturday
or Friday and Saturday oh Saturday you
get tickets all you want Saturday huh
Richmond's I think like two and a half
hours away that's not bad that could be
fun what time is the show uh I think
they're eight and ten or seven and nine
thirty I'm not sure I should have looked
that up yeah maybe there's no vicinity
of that though how many uh what's the
capacity I think it's like 250 250 200
we should sell it out we should I want
to sell it out so if you guys want to
come out and support me the funny bone
it's in Short Pump I'm gonna say 80
chance we're there I like that 85 chance
what do you say this is yeah I like
comedy shows thank you we haven't gone
to Richmond I haven't been to Richmond
in like 10 years did my opener Matt
mccleary's hilarious you're gonna love
it the whole Show's good do they have
food they do have food what kind of food
uh Comedy Club food it's good I'll say
it's good because I'm on air do they
have stuff with like cheese on top of it
like melted yeah oh really see you're
not gonna lose out there 90 it's
actually as far as Comedy Club food goes
it's going to be better that'll be cool
yeah yeah no I think I think we'll go I
think we'll go I think that'll be fun
that'd be awesome let me know you get
tickets and you guys come out I'm
telling you it's gonna be a good time
Saturday and it's Saturday evening so we
we can hang out Richmond during the day
yeah and then come up hang out at night
come up yeah it'd be a good time Luke
said yes already
thank you dude yeah you're 100 maybe
I got stalkers too we got to be careful
here yeah
yeah is there like a secret area yeah
you there's a secret area okay yeah okay
Virginia's open carry right I believe so
yeah I got a desert eagle so that'll be
fun well there you go you're all set
then I'll bring my Barrett there you go
I do have a desert eagle and they were
telling me like that it's like it's like
brittle or something with the firing pin
or something malfunctions or I don't
know they were like it's it's showy but
I like how you were half listening to
someone telling you that yeah yeah it
could blow up in your hand you're like
I'm sorry one
is it a 50 AE uh yeah of course yeah
they have different calories it's got
like skulls on it that's sweet yeah and
like you walk in they're like this is
what people have in movies and I was
like I'll take it yeah that's all they
were like here's how it works I was like
huh I bought two golden guns with snakes
on them like uh face off that's how I
get up have you ever if you've ever
played a video game
I was at a gun shop and they had uh 1911
it was really cool it had like flowers
or something I think it was in 1911 I
don't know maybe maybe it was like oh
there's a glass turn uh like almost uh
roses yeah yeah and then I was just like
I I love making this joke where I'm like
the the Engravings give it like plus one
accuracy because like anyone who's
played a video game knows that like if
you if you find a gun in the game it's
like normal but if it has like the
special Engravings on it for some reason
it's got like lower recoil and like
higher accuracy don't ask me why but the
the you know the Flames coming off the
back make it stronger yeah that's how it
works
at least in video games true imagine
like a world where physics were that way
where it's like oh yes the flame decals
on the side make it uh fire faster with
more powerful impacts yeah how does that
work isn't that like an actual thing
it's like the Orcs in uh that 40K for
him or 40K like they believe it's if
it's red and it's painted red it goes
faster and they have like a psychic oh
really makes it faster so I think that's
literally a thing yeah in uh the
division I haven't played that in a long
time it's like you'll get an M1A or
something but then like this the special
one it's like got more power faster
reload time for some reason your hands
move faster reloading it and it'll have
like Engravings on the side you can like
spin it around
you gotta love how video games work yeah
Craig Cooper says Tim set up a ballot
harvesting consultancy for the
Republicans you understand it so be the
change help them win I'm sure your
millions of millions of viewers will
happily volunteer I would if I were in
the U.S Australia doesn't have this
problem
he could be saying Austria but I think
it's Australia there are people who know
way more about Maryland uh ballots and
battle everything than I do so there's
like there's nothing I can really say
other than like hey I read the news one
time no there's a bunch of people who
are like James O'Keefe probably knows
way more about this stuff than I do
so well Scott Pressler just said he was
going to start ballot harvesting he said
I'm going to be the biggest ballot
Harvester there is this election all we
need is to secure funding for his
organization of get at the vote and
about harvesting where legal and it's
legal in many many states so uh and some
states that have regulation you just got
to get they have to sign off so
basically someone can hand you the
ballot and sign something saying this
person will deliver it for me and that's
legal uh if that's the case then we got
to secure funding I think we could
easily pull it off for sure I think
Scott's the game well that's what he
said he said I was the best voter
registration Harvester there was I'm
gonna start harvesting the balance now
let's go well yes but we need to get him
a team of like 500 yes yes absolutely
maybe more than that we need volunteers
in every state he needs offices he's
going to need the um like save America
get out the vote pack or something or
like you know re rebuild America pack
and this is what he does I bet I bet he
could get a lot of money for that I mean
it I'm I'm willing he would be the one
to do it Peter Thiel gave a bunch of
money to Blake Masters I guess I'm sure
I'm sure there's a lot of yes powerful
patrons who would fund an operation to
ensure that every vote counts and that
every person has their voice heard
Democrats can't argue with that that's
what they're all about yeah they want to
make sure that everybody matters well
there's how Joe got into office he
matters the safest most secure election
ever the most votes ever ever most
popular president in history very
popular yes yeah yeah and that's a good
guy all right Aaron Brandt says support
for ligma and segma two families put
down in shame Through the Ages
we have the best commentaries I'm in the
comment section every night it's awesome
Miss Lauren says bought Lord and Lady
titles for my grandchildren awesome gift
a tree is planted too I gave you as a
referral thank you great Xmas gift I do
think so myself and
um I I actually think it would be really
funny and I'm not trying to say anybody
should do this but I'm imagining I'm
gonna get a call from my uh my ads guy
and he's like why why are they hitting
me up saying they've sold 3 000 ligma
Johnson Lordships
it's like well that's 3 000 square feet
that is that is owned by ligma Johnson
and then someone's gonna have to go to
Scotland and be like this plot of land
is mine they're surrounding one guy's
land there's a guy named ligma Johnson
somewhere who's like how do I own all
this land yes this is great yeah one day
you just get some willed to him
like a guy finds him and he's like are
you ligma Johnson I am and then he pulls
out the envelope and he's like this land
is yours and he's like what every day of
my life has been pain
[Laughter]
oh man I Finally Found You ligma Johnson
I I kind of want to buy one so I could
have the plaque that says lowered the
ligma Johnson oh I'm going to for real
somebody should buy that one too
I like that one
all right chandy's creation says Dave's
response to the conjecture that Nancy
Pelosi takes pills listen to her when
she walks she sounds like a Maraca that
deserves its moment in the Limelight
we went to Gettysburg and I went to a
gift shop and they had like designer
pill containers oh really yeah like a
little fancy metal one with like symbols
on it I opened it up and it was just
like
empty with like a divider in the middle
and I'm like is it because you like got
to put your pills in each side and then
close it and then put it in your pocket
when you go around
that's what she uses I guess maybe she
got hers in Gettysburg
it's weird that that would be at a shop
in Gettysburg they had a bunch of them I
mean I I guess the people who care old
people who go to visit yeah the people
kept the Civil War are the people who
remember it you know well I went a lot
to Gettysburg yeah my dad was a huge
history buff so I went to all those
places when I was like a kid I saw like
JFK in the theater when I was eight wow
yeah
he was in nam yeah he saw some stuff he
started dead he sure did so awesome
stuff all right
legumoth again says I'm confused what's
so funny about that ligma guy's name
you know I I don't know it's just it's a
meme it just works Elon Musk made a joke
you know and so we're just laughing
because we're all in on it yeah
I think ligma forget is a little j a
little jealous yeah right ligma is a
little out of line right now
uh the guy wears shoes says I hear the
ligma forest has great foliage foliage
it does it is nice in the wet Seasons as
well
yeah
very moist Seth weather says you have to
visit Mary Easter domain ending you know
the thing maryeaster.com what is it oh
yeah we gotta get the let's go Brandon
Christmas wrap Seth weather is uh
so that's a good deal what was it do you
remember the link to that
Brandon rapper oh man Brandon rapping
I forgot the website Seth
sure you can find this one that child
give it to us yeah someone will chat it
I that I think that's really great
because I was saying like for Christmas
you give people presents in that and
it's like you're giving them a present
but if it's like one of your woke family
members you're also kind of insulting
them oh yeah that's what I give it just
Maga paper I'm gonna give I'm just gonna
be when they open it's a picture of
trump
make America great again did you see
what I tweeted the I used the stable
diffusion Ai and I typed in high res
photo of Donald Trump with bulging
muscles and a hot bud
and it actually made it and uh I just
thought it was the funniest thing ever
so I'd screenshotted it and posted it
with hashtag Maga and like leftists
thought it was real like like they
thought that I was seriously
I don't know what they thought they were
like this guy likes Trump I'm like dude
I'm making fun of him like it is it is a
joke I don't think they understand how
to take anything as a joke like I don't
think they get humor a lot of them they
don't just eludes them like the fact
that you typed in something so specific
and Google was like here you are not
always stable the future yes yeah sorry
an AI generated that image for you and
it's Donald Trump on the unlike Arnold's
body it looks great yeah and it looks
oddly real I know I like the Rand Paul
one yeah I did uh Ron Paul I said uh Ron
Paul saving puppy high-res photo Ron
Paul saving puppies from a disaster yeah
and it's he's like he's holding a bunch
of a bunch of puppies somebody commented
they were like Tim it's an AI you can't
actually increase the resolution and I'm
like my guy it's a style
when you Google search high-res photo
you get a particular kind of image when
you tell the AI what it does is it looks
at what the internet has and then tries
to create effects and movement I know
the resolution won't be increased by it
but it tries to make it look like how
they look
if you type in something like Ron Paul
saving puppies I got I got a cartoon you
know I I did Joe Biden as Superman and
it was like
a very crude drawing of Joe Biden I'm
like okay so I need high-res photo and
then it makes it you know I hope that we
get Terminators and that's who they
start sending back yeah you know
sometimes stuff like that well we made a
t-shirt it's actually a pinned in the
chat right now it's uh super Maga I
typed into the AI Donald Trump going
Super Saiyan and uh you know when like
Goku and his hair like turns black to
get one of those for real yeah we sold
like I think we've sold a couple
thousand of them already but I made it
as a joke and then when Donald Trump
announced I was like oh I mean like yeah
we have this kamagamaga and he's yelling
and his hair is golden like you know
Goku so yeah that's a good one but the
AI made it I thought it was cool I feel
like there's a lot of Boomers who are
gonna wear that unironically
yeah I actually
this is crazy because I tweeted the
image out because I thought it was funny
and then I I'm I've seen people start
posting it in their profile pictures and
on Instagram and stuff like they really
think it's funny and I'm like okay well
you can buy it you know and and wear it
and it's hilarious
you know the funny thing is I went to a
bar and they had one of those flags
where Trump is writing a velociraptor
with like an Uzi or something yeah and
there's like explosions all around oh
that one's the best stuff like that and
then I'm just like these leftists see
these pictures online and they're like
it's a cult and I'm like no dude they're
self-aware you're not right the fact
that you think they're an occult proves
you're an occult because they know it's
stupid they know they're joking about
Trump being an old man and they're
making they're making like they're not
mocking Trump so much as they're they're
laughing at a meme about Trump right you
know this depiction of him is riding a
dinosaur what's even like him and
Putin's shirtless on a horse you're not
actually getting angry about it like
there's no reason to it's just funny
right right
yeah when they make stuff like that and
they're like haha you're offended and
I'm like nah that's pretty funny no it's
good I think you landed it thanks yeah
just search your whole day I'm like not
at all you threatening to kill me every
time I make a joke that hurts my day
yeah I mean even really yeah it's like
you know what I mean crying into the
wind they could never do that stuff with
Barney though they could never make them
you know a photo of buying with
explosions writing Velociraptor and you
know on a tank and it works they tried
with dark Maga oh the dark brand and
stuff I didn't understand that they were
taking that seriously but they genuinely
try to say it like it's a good thing
like oh dark Brandon wins again but they
don't they don't get it Like Donald
Trump is an arrogant blowhard so making
images of him wearing like golden armor
with giant with a giant Spear and iron
fists is like you're making fun of this
idea what is easy you know like just
stuff like that like it all works when
when you do it with Biden you're like it
doesn't work because what would make
Biden funny is him wearing like you know
those pajamas that would cover your
whole body
yes yeah like Joe Biden wearing that and
like fumbling about or would be a funny
example stick and a night cap and going
to bed yeah right right all right yeah
like that is like a way to depict Joe
Biden because you're exaggerating what
people say about him yeah staying in a
basement never debate stuff like that
you have to make fun of yeah and then
you exaggerate it that's why it's funny
about Trump because he can be ridiculous
you personify that and multiply by a
thousand we got a good one from James
derryberry says ligma Johnson hardwood
preservation quote I wish a million
seeds
that nailed it we should definitely call
it the ligma Johnson hardwood
preservation I'm down
they built like a pavilion there and
then do events yeah and that'll be made
of the hardwood the very hard wood we
promised to preserve and every time we
take down some wood we plant new wood
yeah we always want more wood yeah you
know we're not going to just leave we're
just gonna take wood and let it yeah to
grow again yeah monsters
come on guys Lars Jobe says my paternal
grandpa had full-on Parkinson's in the
late 80s but somehow was still allowed
to keep his license in Cali Road shotgun
with him to his avocado Grove along
winding Canyon Road six months before it
was revoked White Knuckles and a change
of drawers for men that's not a good
story yeah I've I've ridden in a car
with some older family members and
you know I I look legit you're going
like whoa whoa a lot yeah my Grandma had
like a Sunfire and I'm not sure if she
hit people I just remember being very
scared as a child
she was insane for some reason I just
I'm too afraid to get in cars these days
I like driving I do I like cars I always
have but yeah there's just uh a lot of
old people who uh some are sharp though
but sometimes you just got to give the
Gran Torino to the Asian neighbor boy
here's something interesting scrotz
mcgoat says Luke I was banned on Twitter
five years ago I appealed last week and
was reinstated Tuesday sweet congrats
welcome back to the party
William tresh says Dave Frankenstein is
the name of the doctor the monster's
name is John federwoman you are
absolutely right I'm sorry and actually
I'm I I don't know if that's true that
Meme where they're like Frankenstein was
the name of the doctor the monster is is
what's called Frankenstein's monster and
I'm like I'm pretty sure the monster was
called Frankenstein I think it was when
the people in the city turned out to be
the monster I mean that was really the
thing wow but now it's the guy
yeah
well there you go for sure but you know
then it was the people who didn't accept
the monster who was made by a lightning
bolt that's true body parts and then
they got a white dug up Raymond g
Stanley Jr says Ashley say water coffee
you gotta Northeast oh they always do
this to me they did this to me last time
they said what did someone say they said
she sounds like she's from New Jersey I
want her to be mean to me one of your
questions why because when you say water
and coffee water
coffee I have no idea where are you from
coffee
yeah she's got is that where you're from
though born yeah my mom is yeah yeah so
she always you have the coffee well
she's my mom's from New York and she's
Jewish so I didn't really have a choice
yeah you're gonna get that Gene what's
your dad all right he's French is he
it's French okay do you speak like very
very white okay no I don't speak French
oh we got a good one here from uh Jewish
Noah Zork he says if you build a private
Airfield you can name it ligma Landing
Strip
so we'll get the land we'll put a
landing strip on it and it'll be the
ligma landing strip oh yeah we have to
be able to get planes in
that's right
like we need a car
too yeah I'm just imagining how we're
like laughing how stupid this is and
then you know like 100 years later
there's like this resort called the
ligma Johnson family Retreat on this
like privately owned land it's open to
the public we have to have a fire
department but they can't shoot water
it's all the foam I went to uh there's
this Resort in near Pittsburgh called
Nemacolin and it's the family that did
84 Lumber and they like when you go in
there there's this little section where
they have a documentary playing like
explaining the life of the guy who
founded it like it would just be funny
if you had that and it's like showing
pictures of like the show and it's like
in the year 2022. several personalities
were speaking at a table and decided to
make a joke about fellatio and then they
got people to donate money to buy this
land that you're you're on now which is
why the planet is now called Lakewood
yeah it's like a hundred years later
there's like a Civil War and then they
use that as like the main base it
becomes the capital of the resistance
and then when they win they're just like
the boundaries expand and then before
anybody realized it it's like did you
know there's a bunch of roads in Iraq
that are named after like football
players and things like that and is it
really yeah because what I heard was
that when the in Afghanistan too when
U.S troops went there and they started
driving and creating paths they didn't
have names so they would just be like uh
Brett Favre or something like that like
what can we call it no take a right on
farv and so then they ended up making
roads based off of sports players or
things they knew yeah so like you know
ligma Johnson is where everyone lives
and then someone builds a farm not
realizing they're expanding the
boundaries but they just say I live in
ligma Johnson and then just because of
the natural flow of human expansion 100
years later it's just like the country
of Luke Johnson yeah this is the jack me
off Resort right
and then like that's the town of anal
fissures that grew up next door that one
that one is just very direct yes well
that was
it's like the Hatfield and McCoys though
this is what starts the whole Civil War
the anal faces
what what a very important episode
they're very uncomfortable people
Andrew Hughes says remember when San
Francisco news also got stung with
Asiana plane crash Pilots Captain some
Ting Wong we too low holy fuk bang ding
ow yeah Luke brought that up yeah but
we'll read that one
Matt Bayer says shout out to grindstone
Ministries and bear independent for
doing what FEMA isn't in Oklahoma
right on yeah that's true Daniel Welch
says ligma Johnson must ligma Johnson
Forest must have a natural geyser yes
we're going to Wyoming it goes off could
you imagine if like the founding fathers
were just sitting there like writing
things down and laughing about it like
this like and then we're going to tell
them that you know everybody gets to
vote it's all John Hancock
[Laughter]
let me get your John Hancock come on
it's not even your name I know I know
but we didn't do it like this
Mr MC Jones ligma Johnson candle scent
morning wood this whole episode is
basically just us talking about ligma
Johnson and it all started right before
we said people are too stupid
well we've proved it well no to to to
actually uh you know make the point we
know what a joke is yes they don't
like Brandon Joy gray is a progressive
she didn't understand that they were
joking like they just it's crazy NPC
meme all the way man she's gonna have a
lot of content from this episode yeah we
had when we would do that with video
announcements in high school I mean
that's just like anybody should know
what that is you know like how do you
not know that joke and she's like I
don't understand why why there'd be a
name like that let's read one last Super
Chat
Chrissy Starsky saying how about the
ligma Johnson finishing school for young
ladies I saw that one I'm like I'm not
reading that one all right everybody if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
become a member at timcast.com we're
gonna have a members only show coming up
for you uncensored not family friendly I
have a very short song to play for you
when we start the members only show that
you're not going to want to miss and it
will give you a good laugh and then
we'll talk about some cultural issues so
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
become a member and uh Ashley do you
want to shout anything out uh nope I
accept the Babylon B and you can also
find me on Twitter at Sinclair Ashley
of course a lot louder with Crowder and
then you can uh check me out uh in
December at The Comedy Castle the 8th
through 10th recording my special at
prison 10. where were you going tomorrow
and tomorrow the next two days I will be
at uh Short Pump in Virginia at the
Richmond Funny Bone sweet Dave that was
awesome thank you so much for coming on
we should uh Ashley as well this was
incredible this was uh really uh uh very
very serious show I love to have such
professional shows here it's it's my jam
but my YouTube channel is we are change
I just did a Biden fetterman short on
there I did a really interesting video
earlier and yes we do have a ligma
Johnson t-shirt we do have of course the
Biden fetterman t-shirt all available on
thebstpoliticalshirts.com this is how
you guys support me and my efforts here
so I appreciate you guys very much thank
you again so much for having me
thanks guys for coming that was uh good
to laugh uh kind of don't get that too
much in this line of work my name is
serge.com thanks guys we will see you
all over at timcast.com just about an
hour or so thanks for hanging out cheers